we're back we're back and ready to
attack with all this
oh whoa
[Music]
her enemies begins now wow the frenemies
experience
lightning bolts
begins today we're sponsored by me
undies blue chew and quip we love them
we appreciate them don't we folks
we love them love them okay frenemy's
beanie
you look so skinny today you said you
weren't any legend every weekend but you
look skinny
the first thing i saw i was like oh my
god you're skinny maybe it's a huge
because i have like a huge shirt on
but i was telling you okay so me and ela
went to vegas
over the weekend for a little getaway no
weird
since we got vaccinated we're like well
let's just you know let's go
do something i never see you out of the
house i was like where are they what are
they doing
yeah and you guys were like gucci
shopping
playing poker at hotels i'm like what is
happening
yeah it's fun we're vaccinated it was so
crowded though bro i was like all right
i'm putting this vaccine to the full
dash in vegas it was crowded because
everybody's like
you know the vac so everyone wants to do
what we did
where they're like okay it's kind of
there's we can if you're vaccinated and
they go
in vegas if your vaccine you can take
your mask off it's like as if
these these stupid anti-vaxxers are
gonna be honest about it yeah do you
take your mask off
yeah i did the cdc put out a statement
saying yeah
if you're vaccinated you could take your
mask off so i was like all right let's
go dr fauci
is it anywhere you take your mask off
inside too whoa
that's why everyone went to vegas and so
um
let's see i was like i was like the ela
this is the ultimate test for this
vaccine god could you imagine
if i feel good though don't say it yeah
like what have you got outside
no like if you got it and you got the
vaccine like i i got a little stuffed up
last week and i was thinking like
did i get covered like okay let me
explain yeah you
obviously the vaccination is 95
effective so you still have a five
percent chance but if you do
catch it the severity of the illness is
greatly greatly reduced oh okay cool so
like even if you do catch it post
vaccination
you're still greatly benefit from
getting the vaccination which everybody
please should do thank you very much for
this psa
but um anyway about me being skinny when
we took the jet
when we took the the flight over i was
buckled in did you have a jet it's like
oh my god no no we didn't no no no okay
no it's not it's like out of it's this
service where it's like a private jet
but it's like commercial
other people are on it yeah other people
are on it you like it's like jet x or
something yeah that's exactly
right it's not that bougie yeah yeah no
exactly okay okay thank you you could
get a private jet why would i need to
this one is so
it's the same thing i can't do private
job i i think i'd be too
sad to waste the money i can spend 40
000 again but 10 000.
the the private jet is so expensive you
can't even imagine no that's like 10 000
to vegas
but it's like a 45 minute flight
yeah yeah i mean and then like i've
heard people they fl
who fly private from like new york like
you know cross country
it's like 50 000 100 000 i was like
excuse me
no [ __ ] way yeah daddy daddy needs
some cheddar for this trailer lawsuit
you're in a good mood for me
oh yeah trailer's trying to take my
triller's coming after me you seem you
seem not happy about but you seem like
okay with it i watch your show thursday
you seem very like you know
well you know what because here let me
finish my fat story
so the point is when i was on the jet i
was buckled in
and i go look ila it's it's all the way
it's like extended to the max and that
and it fit me
do you understand what i'm saying yeah i
could not possibly be
any bigger it's so you know what though
you're really skinny it's literally
just your middle i know that's what i i
have a freak body dude when we got
measurements for one of the outfits the
taylor was like
this [ __ ] there's this is not right what
you're telling me
the taylor was like there's something
wrong here he told him never seen a body
language he told us that
we were measuring incorrectly we went
back and we did it
we went shopping for pants because we
went to like a nice dinner and i don't
have any pants because i refuse to buy
pants because i
i'm like i'm gonna lose weight what size
pants are you okay 36.
bro are you [ __ ] kidding me i was 36
when i was skinny
guess my actual waist size you're more
than 36 now
no you have a youtube 42 no where did
you find 42's
exactly at a designer brand so we had
this
design it was amazing no i went i went
i got a shirt from the gucci store and
they were showing us like
pants that i really liked and wanted and
so i i [ __ ] you not
they're like here's the biggest size we
have in the whole store it goes
up to like here do you understand what
i'm saying
here this is all yeah designer brands
are not made for
us i've never been able to fit into
anything i had to get a louis vuitton
men's xxl for that like leather jacket i
wore
oh that's a good idea but that was
already oversized for men so it didn't
fit me like perfect so like they do
but it's good it saves me money like so
i had to go get there was this one store
where they tailor the pants for you
which store was it
i don't i don't remember the name i had
some weird names the pants are really
nice though well you should shop them
out for the fatties
i wish i could but you can't go i don't
remember
you don't remember the story you got him
no it had like a really weird name
in vegas yeah what area were you and
were you in the crystals were you in the
aladdin shops or
it wasn't that really the mall with all
the designs fashion show mom
yeah or crystals i don't know was it a
mom mall or were you like walking it was
a mall like a caesar's palace no
it was a mall mall it's a fashion trip
next to bellagio
okay okay i just want to know where you
got these things well anyway i got these
i got these 42s and
boy i have the biggest [ __ ] dump
truck wait
you do you have another what i think i
don't know what's my body
like even when i was skinny my waist
size was 36 that's why i always thought
i was fat
it's it's you have the adam sandler body
you just got the bigger hips and the
bigger butt
he has the same body well apparently
he's a sex icon
he is tick tock is going crazy right i'm
saying right now so
yeah um yeah so anyway um oh next friend
of me's merch
i know we haven't done the first launch
for the second launch we should do
basketball shorts like pink and black so
adam sandler
oh yeah sure and malibu because he plays
basketball there he's there this weekend
i know where he goes but i can't go hang
out there because it's weird i'm sure he
knows of me
like because i'm like weirdly obsessed
with him he's like oh you know he would
see you and be like
yeah no i would you know i would feel
the same way but i know where he plays
he was there this weekend
weren't you looking for him over the
weekend well that was a joke i wouldn't
actually go to the basketball court we
were just going i thought you were
serious
no well you were there in malibu on the
weekend i did bring the adam sandler
first
i think you are kind of hoping to run
into him i don't know how much of a joke
it is
no i wouldn't honestly i won if i saw
him because i know he would think i'm
creepy like i just anyways
you have the same body as adam sandler
and honestly 42 is the new like 32
uh 42 is still 42. 42 is
is everything you got a badonk and i and
i remember
with peace and love to you is that when
we did the parachute bit when we were
running with the parachute i love the
story yeah and then
so you took off your belt and you took
it off yeah
i took off my belt and i gave it to
trisha to clip on and it was so
massive compared to your wedding that
was everything we should have shown that
i think damn what's your waist size uh
it's about 36 36 yeah i dream of being
36
you're probably a little twink ass 32
what are you
no we bought him 33's and they wouldn't
fit for disneyland his little
his little badank couldn't get in there
either it's all the big zd 34 34 is
great
we've been we've been we've been eating
really good but you know what i have the
opposite effect of you because i did get
liposuction on my way so my waist is
pretty is is pretty small but
everything else because i've had
liposuction i just gained fat like in my
shoulders and in my
wrist oh is that how it works yeah like
the fat gets redistributed because i had
i had lipo here but you can't have it
here because of the veins
you try to get life on your forearm yeah
because i got this done up here this
used to be a lot bigger oh that's
correct and so i
wanted to get this but they have the
veins so they can't they can't you know
stab you in there i guess or whatever
and then i also got my back and my
stomach
but because of that my fupa is larger my
shoulders are larger like everything
else
gains so my fingers are fatter like
everything's so much oh
you know i'm like i'm like a size like
nine and a half interesting yeah so um i
have the opposite we have like the
reverse inverse bodies of each other oh
that's interesting your body just plumps
up everywhere else
yeah and my my thighs are huge but
but i think it's better to have a big
belly especially as a guy because that's
a sign of like you eat good you have
money
you know like that's the big bellies are
in it's not
listen it ain't hard to get a big belt
let me tell you it's not that luxurious
well i saw tick tock uh over the weekend
about why
as a fat person someone else talking
about why they can't be with another fat
person
and it's because like there's too much
too many bellies and too much oh yeah
and all that stuff
if i was with somebody with the equal
size of meme i would never be able to
get it in
same same like sitting on someone with a
poopo with my football there's just too
much
even even with ela being like the
skinniest person alive it's like
that's not true you're not that big you
really aren't
i think your stomach is proportionate
it's just yeah i have a weird body
but you are skinny and your belly's not
even that big it's just because you're
so thin right here
anyway i'm trying to lose weight no you
actually look really good and you know
what's funny
how how much conversation being fat
takes up on this show
like if you if you look at all of the
history of this show
yeah we probably spent at least 10 hours
talking about being about what other
podcast offers
this kind of this insight none yeah none
on the planet other than
that we're fat we are big fat fat
fatties is a podcast where they talk
about it
you know what i loved you know what i
loved rosie o'donnell back in the day
because she talked about being fat and
she always got redemption for being fat
remember when donnie osmond made fun of
her weight he's like oh we won't both
film the helicopter and then everyone
was like oh poor rosie and she got like
this huge like
arc of like followers and stuff like i
think that's like i literally went
anyways i want fat redemption so anyway
i think we have a little sympathy for us
because we're fat i think people just
like that we don't
that we're like open about our flaws and
stuff you know what i mean yeah well
we're getting to the topic but that's
why when someone's like oh they're
bullies i'm like
we don't we hate ourselves more than
anybody i think we're more
self-deprecating you know
yeah yeah yeah i feel like i'm harder on
myself than anybody on the internet like
i literally
hate myself every day i look at myself
naked although i like myself some days
but
whatever people say i'm like really
contradicting myself all the time but i
wouldn't say
i don't i wouldn't say i hate myself i
mean there's been times in my life when
i've been self-loathing when i was like
really depressed but
do you hate your body oh yeah yeah
that's what i'm talking about
i meant the body i don't hate myself i
hate my body i love it but it's all
because i mean it's my own fault
you know it's like i've i've neglected
my body no you have a disorder you have
issues with food you have you know
it's like it's a thing in our brain
obviously it's easy we know how to
dye it but like it's a thing in the
brain you know what i mean
they were you've seen goodwill hunting
where robin goes it's not your fault
will
oh the guy's name is will in the movie
yeah will hunting's his name
did you miss that i never saw the movie
it's so good i liter
but anyway there's a scene where he goes
it's not your fault well why is it good
will hunting why is it just not will
hunting why is it good will hunting
because he's good
i know it's a play on words yeah like
goodwill
yes trisha this is like a 30 year old
movie it's sponsored by goodwill
it's a great film though i love that
movie uh i don't like man you know what
i'm talking about it's an iconic scene
yeah that's what trish is doing
right now it's not your fault ethan i
know i don't know ooh
and then he goes it's not your fault and
he starts crying and going it's not your
fault
oh are you gonna start crying are you
the will hunting in this yes and i'm the
robin williams
yes i knew robin williams
yeah but let me guess you [ __ ] him he
was
he you are yeah he i don't want to talk
about now that he's a ceasefire i did do
a storytime one time and he was really
really nice but i don't like going to
detail how i know
but he was really nice and he did he
wait how do you know him i don't
know you better tell me now i don't want
to go like how do you know was it an
escort thing i think i talked about it
before you can google it if you want if
someone find it i don't know
don't find it don't i just you know when
someone's dead like i hate when people
talk about people when they died
right now you just told me to no i was
because he was married and i just don't
want to watch trisha paytas
oh so you were a prostitute and you
hooked up with robin um
it was like well he's known he's known
for
you know doing that stuff yeah but he
was really like like again
was he a good lover he was really nice i
don't want to talk about it
i just feel like it's so disrespectful i
don't want him to like roll you know
what he means you think he'll haunt you
that's flubber
wasn't he flubber what is lover
uh flubber was one of the movies that
was really dumb oh wait no flubber
that's flubber yeah not a flubber
wait am i spelling it wrong you're right
yes flubber hello people flubber are you
guys forgetting about this classic film
uh flubber oh my god is that me and the
red hair do you see right there
look to the left is that me you wish oh
oh i thought it was me i was like oh my
god
hello this is the guy you [ __ ] we love
him i didn't i didn't say that i
just you know respect to his scene did
he flubber your ass
stop i wasn't flubbery back then i was i
was a lot thinner than i am now
did he give you the old flub club some
people say i look like robin williams
actually
stop nobody says that you better stop
that [ __ ] right now
you better stop saying that [ __ ] to me
well
anyways he i met him oh that's so
interesting of course you had sex with
robin williams that's your
you have had sex with like every
celebrity it seems like
but nobody knows these celebrities
anymore so it's not that much of a flex
like tana
you told me a crazy one that's a secret
uh
did i mm-hmm because you're like very
persistent i'm being like who is it who
hasn't because it's so interesting
yeah but i don't i don't know is it
because it's kind of like i don't know
i just um you attacked with robin
williams no
i didn't say that yes you did okay let's
move on oh my god
i mean i mean that's amazing that you
crossed paths with this incredible
person i did cross paths with them yeah
but it's not a cool flag you cross
genitals with them people nowadays can
flex that they slept with like takashi
six nine like those kind of people are
yeah
that's not a flex right no they're not
that's like that's like you better get
the plan
planned parenthood immediately i feel
like rappers are the flags oh little lil
xan
why is that why are these all these tiny
little weird like pseudo-rappers i just
follow tana and those are the people
that and i'm like oh she's she's hooking
up with cool people i
i don't think my relevancy of people
i've hooked up with is up to par
uh robin williams is by far a much
cooler [ __ ] than little zan
i'm sorry what wow really little zan is
like he looks like a little baby
and he's like a little baby too get out
get
out i have no idea what he looks like
actually i just really let me show you
no let's not make
people's appearance yeah let's not be
bullies because i feel like we we pride
ourselves on not making fun of people's
appearances like i know how
bad that sucks for people yeah i don't
like low blows you know
right good point but at the same time
when people make fun of my appearance
sometimes i take it as like
i take it as flattering you know what i
mean sometimes depending on like i mean
the thing is i definitely there's
nothing anybody could say about my
parents that would actually upset me
because you've heard it your whole life
so you're just numb to it now you're
just like i guess
how many times i guess it's like the old
saying where like you wear it as a
shield because i always make fun of my
appearance
but it doesn't feel good like it
definitely doesn't feel it doesn't hurt
at all
it doesn't hurt me it's just more like
you do
because it's like oh you went there okay
let's [ __ ] go hence because if it's
about like my appearance like
me boobs the way i talk like whatever
but like if it's a crying on the kitchen
floor but if it's like
oh she's fat it's like oh that's kind of
like that's it that's all you can yeah
yeah i agree it's like okay
let's go i'm faster [ __ ]
anyway so i know what the [ __ ] are we
talking about how good you were
do we want to go back no okay should we
go on that private jet maybe that
private jet was meant for skinny people
i'm following a lawsuit
okay what's the handicap organization
that sues everyone
hey no uh anyway i'm doing that but fat
you know what southwest would not be
that doing that to you because southwest
has those extra large buckles straps for
days yes they have the straps for days
that's why i love
those soft westerners i'll tell you why
we down here in the southwest we got
extra long straps boy
yeah super wide i have a jet start for
skinny people
i'm not fat shaming it's like designer
exactly
but what they're like they're like fat
people do not
ride private let's be honest i don't so
i guess that's a fact right there
i'm one of the statistics of fat people
who don't write private they don't shop
designer
and they don't ride private they go
first class because they're fat
fat people ride in like they'd like
drive
no that's too much or like they well
what are they gonna do
they spent all their money on food i
can't breathe when i'm in a car trip
because i have to like bend over to get
snacks and
i can't you know it hurts i don't like
it but you're a rich fat person
ah let's stop this conversation right
now
please i'm being sued by triller [ __ ]
okay am i part of this no although
no i see my clip being here yeah yeah
there's a clip of us
talking together but they're not suing
i'm silent in that clip by the way i'm
just like
you're like i didn't even notice at the
time i really didn't even i didn't
notice anything that was
i didn't to me i just thought i was like
a joke and then i was like oh damn
no who cares this is my problem i joke
and now i'm worried i'm like what did i
say that i could get sued in my life i'm
sure a lot
you just got to live your life girl yeah
people don't like that like you well
i've been
i've been sued once before by by this
dude matt hoss for the same thing and we
took him all the way to court and we won
i'm about to do that again i sued a
wayans
brother aunt brother son and i won
and i never got the money yeah that's
the problem when you can't sue
poor people no he had money i was
renting his house three million dollar
house
and i stood and i won and all i was
doing for is twelve thousand because
that was the the what he owed me
how did they get away with not paying
you
no he's not broke because he sold the
house i don't know he just is not paying
me and i'm like i really needed that
money at the time i mean i guess if he
needs it okay but it's all way
better than what i'm gonna be like when
triller if triller wins i'll be like hey
i'm broke now but trailer's gonna go
under it because they're sponsoring
jason's
oh triller by the way trailer is
definitely gonna go out of business
these people are so desperate and so
spending money so much
and now obviously they're suing me which
means like oh
uh our our our we sold a gajillion
pay-per-view and we had justin bieber
it's like okay so why exactly are you
suing me
to try to like peer pressure and people
just spending 4.99
it's like one of those things where oh
no
anyway if listen because i feel like you
don't have my back right now
i always have your back we want to go to
war with thriller we're going to roll
with killers
i'm about to blow the foghorn are you
going to be with me oh
i'm gonna i have a lawyer we're gonna go
over everything i'll make sure your
coach
coach yeah because i'm jewish almost
it's
it's more of a j it's more of a uh
general term yeah
it has nothing to do with you being
jewish thank you which you aren't
just to be clear thank you
for that clarity for everybody but if
you just needed another reason to help
support me against this tr
this on let me think of like a really
close okay
so this is jason's new this is the jason
nash show he was paying people like ten
dollars for
eight hours of work so they apparently
wait are we sure about this it says
trilled studios are we sure there's an
association
i'm pretty sure it's triller
well why is woody right trilled and why
is there a dude on a banjo doesn't say
trilled
it says true good because we don't see
the end of the army why don't you just
open the video
how much research are we doing on this
show
what we know it says trill oh triller
what studio i thought it said trilled
yeah i was oh i thought you were being
stupid
no i'm actually dumb i'm actually done
self-deprecating right there
trailer studios well could somebody open
the [ __ ] video and actually see if it
says troller studios like it's not that
much to ask over my research team
well i didn't i don't think anybody even
had the thought that you just had
it's definitely that because we put our
pieces i put i was detective work over
the weekend so i definitely know it's
okay so then there's what i'm saying
like trailers supporting jason nash
vis-a-vis
you are in the trenches with me now
imagine yeah yeah for sure
oh my god for sure yeah oh yeah why why
because are we have share we have common
enemies what do you mean
okay yeah yeah right
wait what i don't want to agree to
something
why am i why am i on it because you hate
jason okay and they support jason
then you hate him i don't hate him i
think he's a disgusting creep that
shouldn't be on the internet
okay you think he's just such a group
that should be able to backing that
you're
that's another creep trailer well you
know what other creep trillers backing
jake paul i don't know a lot about jake
paul but
well i do know that i do know that the
new york times wrote a profile on him
that was that was exhaustedly uh
as the author said on our show carefully
vetted
that it credibly accused jake paul of
being a
rapist oh and triller
backs jake paul jake paul is a partial
owner of triller
and some people have speculated even
further
not myself of course but people on the
internet have speculated even further
that this is a spite
lawsuit fueled by jake paul and that's
obs
because in their original lawsuit they
listed like 20 people
and they're like we're going after all
these people and then the judge is like
this is a
the dumbest thing i've ever read it's an
improper jointer it means they put
everyone together improperly so the
judge threw out the lawsuit and then
guess who they filed
of those 20 people guess who they
refiled against only yeah
right fascinating
yeah yikes i don't know i feel so i
don't know
i wish i was a little it's a fair use
i'll just say it's a i just want to make
very clear
it's a fair use lawsuit they are suing
me for watching a
clip of the fight on my show that's what
they're shooting days after the fight
five days after the fight i watched 45
seconds commented over the whole thing
it is literally fair use what i do
every day day in day out and i need to
[ __ ] put my foot down
against people that are threatening not
only my life my
way of life my constitutional first
amendment right
and everybody else on youtube yeah just
like the first time
so this is fair use i feel like we're a
part of history you're like george
washington thank you
sailing across the delaware to meet
hamilton everything comes down to
hamilton
alex you're my right-hand man
how's that song go um am my right hand
man
right um you're by alexander hamilton
how is it oh yeah i'm gonna i'm waiting
in the field for you
you never back down never let it change
the
time
they are waiting in the field for you
you never know they'll
know your name
[Applause]
i'll be there to write your resignation
letter oh yeah when you resign from
when i die you'll write my eulogy i
don't think he died i think he
yeah he resigned his farewell okay thank
you but yeah you're alexander hamilton
do you accept the post is my right hand
man yeah thank you you're going to die
before me then
george washington dies before hamlet
well he's old as [ __ ] though
you he he lived a good long life for
like back then yeah yeah
it's a good job i love i think george
washington's awesome so i'm happy to be
him
uh do you but i think he might have been
a slave owner i don't think he wanted
well everybody was a slave owner but he
was actually from what i understand
like a relatively woke slave owner
because he he freed
i mean no he freed his slaves when he
died
which like you have to take things in
perspective right now just the phrase
woke slightly i know i know you have to
take things in perspective because
during the time this is way before
[ __ ] like
it was you know during the time of the
civil war there was a huge
way before the civil war i'm saying
during the time of the civil war
there was like there was people were
much more aware of like oh we got to end
this thing slavery
back during the days of george
washington literally everybody had
slaves
and so he was a pretty woke slave owner
and that when he died i know it sounds
funny
he freed his slaves which is very odd
yeah but hamilton was more awoke because
he's trying to hamilton
yeah but that that was like radical you
have to understand like back then
like the notion of slave should be free
was like
super radical like what the hell's wrong
with
you
yeah george washington's the [ __ ]
abraham lincoln moore because he
actually freed all the slaves so we
might stand him a little more
i'd watch that i would do i'd watch the
lin-manuel musical about like
me taking a [ __ ] i don't think he would
write that he's sitting on the toilet
about it the fan and
the power wash turns on for you
it's pulsating on his butt stop
i want to die on the toilet like elvis
anyway trailer's gonna go out of
business for sure because like nobody
uses their dumb app
it's horrible it's just a tick tock rip
off their events stuck
don't have you heard of trill or the app
i literally have no idea what this is i
just know they did the fight right
that's the thing
about them oh you don't what didn't you
know about triller the tick tock rip
oh no oh so there's this uh so they're
primarily a media company that has like
a tick top rip
off app we're sponsored by trailer
you're like it's actually a tick tock
app
give it a little rundown of what it is
can you imagine if they sponsored us
that'd be the weirdest
thing ever um i don't like it i don't
know what it is
they just rip tip talk off tip top
they just ripped tip top off yeah and so
nobody uses their app because it sucks
and there's nobody
on it like it's just awful like and you
know
they're just hemorrhaging money because
they're trying to pay people to do the
stuff and like
paying jason nash who nobody's going to
watch that and so why is that dude
playing a banjo
okay fine but it's a small guitar dan
you want to split hairs
i mean yeah appears to be uh ukulele oh
even worse
i mean at least welcome to trailer
studio
i'm sorry one star but at least hanging
out with people that are age appropriate
right you know he's trying to improve a
little i guess
he could he could enter into would you
be okay for jason to enter a consensual
sex relationship with that man
what well you said he's with
age-appropriate people
oh okay i guess if he's if he's open to
that
that's fine i don't know i don't really
he might be his relationships he can do
whatever he do but well
well you're saying he's a creep because
he's oh right we're right so
age-appropriate
80-year-old man i'm feeling it yeah yeah
this is more appropriate
it's not like his young girls on the
show now that's a trailer
that's a trailer production i would
watch
i did watch the whole thing looking for
an apology
or at least an acknowledgement bro you
are the biggest hate watcher
no because i wanted to see if he
acknowledged the situation i was like
let me watch it to the end to see if
he's going to acknowledge what
anything that has happened in the past
maybe at the end of the show right he
was trying to do this like
knockoff of eric andre's show oh really
did you not see it
no i didn't even hear about it um no i
just want to do my research in case he
did apologize at the end of it or
something but he didn't even acknowledge
one thing
wait was it not one thing about anything
david actually
well why would he he's trying to like
wait my no i'm saying i'm saying you
should but like why would he even before
this started he just did a quick video
like i was stupid i don't know wait he's
calling the first episode
my new talk show was a disaster like i'm
sorry bro can you [ __ ] hype it up
can you can you like not what is the
views i can't even see that it says 100
and uh 10 000.
um
no trust me i do not i do not hate
watching like i can't even it's like
what's the thing about the show about it
this is so cool sorry
i'm triggered looking at him not in a
bad way
wait he's really trying to be a late
night guy no okay so there's a show
called the eric undershirt i didn't know
this
i know eric andre of course so i went to
go watch it's basically the exact same
things i didn't know
the show oh it's the same format of him
trying to
do this kind of stuff i'm sorry trailer
if this is the best you can do on
production-wise then you really are
going to lose all your money and go out
of business
there's the r triller studios
it's war war never changes do you agree
like
why is the lighting is horrible
[Music]
well here let me hear this what is with
this old guy
are they in a sexual relationship it's
just a comedy
like even with the guests the way he is
i mean i watched both of them so
oh oh there's two i'll ask you a couple
questions yeah sure what's up oh yeah
what's your feeling
chiller's gonna sue me for watching this
now
like you had an unauthorized access to
the jason national part one
the most exposure to the show will have
but we will be so excited
hugely followed instagram page please
welcome nina daniel nina
hi oh my god bro you have to be more
original than that that is
exactly the air conditioner
i'm sorry jason but i mean it's just you
can't rip
you can't do like a carbon copy
um it's fake because
also he doesn't i'm sorry jason i don't
know what he can't pull that off
because eric andre is a literal [ __ ]
psycho madman you know what i mean
like you just i don't know i don't see
it
i mean the only thing i will like you
know i don't know
oh we're gonna well you know i will say
this though is like it is one of those
instances where you see like your ex and
you're just like oh what was i thinking
like this is that moment for me and i'm
so excited i could have
look at moses look at jason i know moses
jason besides from how they act and all
that other stuff like the way they treat
me and stuff like that but like and
obviously he doesn't hang around with
like teenagers but like aside from all
of that
like just the physical looks like i'm
not trying to be mean but like
you know he did leave me in a
psychiatric hospital he looks like death
he looks like death he looks like and i
i don't wish that on him i don't want
him but i hope he
if he's sick he gets help i don't know
why well oh you you think he looks like
he has a grave illness
yeah oh and i don't wish that i hope he
gets help
but if he if he's healthy i wouldn't go
that far he looks
well let me watch the wait let me watch
the second episode you could say
whatever you want
time he saw me i was high on math he was
you know all
i was sickly i was all the stuff because
for three months he strung me along
after bryce hall
i was in a psychiatric ward twice and he
knew this and he kept streaming me along
so then when i was finally on meth they
went to his house i was he's just like
you look like [ __ ] and he blocked me
and now who looks like [ __ ] he looks
like he's on okay wait hold on
hold on hold on okay all right there's
definitely something going on with you
right now
let me watch the second episode i'm
excited because he just looked horrible
but i hope he does well i hope he's
doing well i don't want him to be
unwell i just like that he looks like i
only see one episode
because it just makes me feel better
like wait hold on you said there was two
episodes there's only one no i didn't
see the rest
no probably out today by you know i
wouldn't say i'm
listen i want to support you i don't
think he looks like death
i think he looks he looks rough
well he's had a rough time for sure
yeah let's try to see if we can find a
laugh i think it's okay let's find out
look see what front of my looks all the
time he always told me i was fat and
that's
like death and that i looked strung out
oh bro
when i wasn't even on drugs he's like
you could make fun i didn't say you
couldn't i'm just well i'm not about
making fun of people's looks but like
some people yeah have it comment he knew
i wouldn't mental
twice and continue to string me along
and look at look at what happened to him
karma got him in his face it looks like
he got hit by a shovel
well also this is him he shouldn't be on
camera like that clean him up like well
no this is this is what they did he's
got makeup and hair you know what i mean
like this is
he's got a stylist like this is the best
he can do
i just can't even believe but i don't
think he looks as bad as you were
perceiving him to be i just
i [ __ ] some ugly ugly people and i
can't believe i [ __ ] him ever like
that's
what like but
like you know what i mean he's one of
those moments so when you [ __ ] like
when you [ __ ] like the ugliest dude
ever you've ever [ __ ] what were you
thinking like i just
like what what you know what normally
i'm just like i look back i'm like okay
whatever they were fun or funny but he
wasn't fun funny he was mean to me he
always criticized what i ate he never
liked my family didn't see my family
like he was just like kind of the worst
in every single way and
i i don't know what i'd say let me find
it let me find something fun
advocate basically oh we have to go to
break
i mean go watch the jason national if
you want i don't know no don't watch uh
stay on this channel watch the hd
podcast
you know and then the other person i
want to find a joke i want to find a
laugh
i want you know can we get 15 seconds on
the clock
great all right here we go here's our
first hot topic you fart
what literally not did you i smelled the
ass and i was like
i think you just ripped that totally not
did you oh ethan did you i hate when you
do that [ __ ]
no i didn't fart
[Music]
did you rip ass i swear trisha just
ripped i feel like you did now and i'm
so annoyed by it i did not fart and how
dare you
why would i bring it up do you smelt it
delta you believe that
i don't know what that even are you
ready no
okay the world is it round or flat
i say it's round um it's it's
flat because yo i'm gonna die
it's flat because i'm literally gonna oh
my god i'm gonna die
wait i'm gonna die i'm gonna die if i
keep watching this
you can't like kick an old horse when
he's down you know what i mean go
give him some views give him a thumbs up
bro you're the one that looks like he
has a more of a
more a grave illness well just cuz he
looks like an old horse doesn't mean you
can shoot him in the head you know what
i mean like you just gotta like
live he's a human being like go give him
some views you know
i feel bad like i have a good heart
inside like even though he looks like
trash like i feel like he should get
some subscribers the top comment is
jason is dead inside his eyes are so
empty
exactly exactly it's just like probably
the most accurate title to a video i've
ever read oh
that's brutal oh yeah you know what just
talk about
the set situation at the very least just
talk about why it's wrong so your kids
and other people know
that don't kiss people without their
[ __ ] consent that's a huge thing a
sexual assault is a lot of unwanted
kissing
it's a lot of it people just let it go
because like it's a kiss it's like
should we talk about our sponsors yeah
let's go to the sponsor
jason how do you feel about that cut to
jason
[Laughter]
we should just save this and then cut to
jason oh no but now i ever cut that out
why could he not get it up well we have
bluetooth as our sponsor yeah i know but
could
did jason have performance issues um
let's not talk about it that's too
personal okay hi friends immunities
believes that comfort is about more than
what touches your skin
it's about feeling comfortable in your
skin and that's why me andy's not only
use as sustainable
breathable soft as heck but also gives
you endless
styles to choose from it's a total
comfort inside
and out me and moses share our mandy's
and this is a true story i don't fit in
one pair
well they do go up to four flexible
shout out me on days we're going up to
4xl for the fat asses and i mean that's
good let's go
so the boys who've got to open that belt
all the way they have crazy prince
moses wears these little froot loops
ones that i love i think they're amazing
he has four pairs he might have got them
from you i'm obsessed with them i also
wear them yeah super comfortable right
it's like next level comfort yeah they
have really cool patterns and really
cool comfort and the fabric is
great and doesn't make me break out and
to be honest there's a big fatty whose
legs
like chafe and rub together it makes a
big difference
biker short in there it's really nice
yeah it's listen
they also have a membership never leave
your couch again with a me undies
membership a monthly subscription that
sends new pairs right to your door
for you you don't want to leave your
couch i'll just throw out the old ones
that's what you do now that's posh
living
yeah i never month you'll choose new
undies socks or a bralette and pick the
style and color or print
that feels the most to you fun right
plus enjoy discounted pricing free
shipping and exclusive early access to
new launches
love your butt get the membership our
members get a great offer
right now any first time purchase you
get 15 percent off and free shipping
what
wow mandy's also has a problem free
philosophy if you're not 100 satisfied
with any product for any reason
full refund or exchange no caveats
no questions they'll sniff it just one
time and throw it out
that's the joke i've been saying that
joke literally since the first time we
worked me on these like five years ago
andy's expert over here to get 15 off
your first order and free shipping go to
com slash freddies that's viennese.com
[Applause]
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
finally hey let's chew that blue let and
get rid of those blue
balls right play the tune anime what is
blue chew
guys it's been a hell of a year
personally i feel like i've aged 12
years over the last 12 months if you
know what i mean
and i'm specifically talking about my
aging 12 years okay i don't know that
didn't happen
but it's time to snap out of it because
spring is here and it's time to get
sprung
with bluetooth bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients in viagra and
cellulose but in chewable form
or a fraction of the cost viagra and
cialis that's the drug that gets your
weenwa
yeah but you have to swallow let her do
the swallowing because you're going to
do it stop
it that's obscene blue chews tablets
help men achieve a harder stronger
erection to combat all forms of ed that
stands for erectile
dysfunction blue chew is an online
prescription service so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting a line of pharmacies
it's you know it ships right to your
door in a discrete package
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you will
receive your prescription within days
the best part is it's all done online
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredients
strength for your prescription don't
like swallowing pills
no problem here because i'm gonna chew
it like
if mmm too like when i
i'm gonna chew it like i chew carpet
okay
gross yeah yeah well chews uh
i don't know how to say this sildenafil
sila silden
phil why they make me say that still
dana phil
sildenafil and tada tadala phil
what do you say when your dick is
magically hard
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they are prepared and shipped direct
so it's cheaper than at a pharmacy
listen if you think you could benefit
from the extra confidence when it's time
to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we have a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew for free when
you use our code
frenemies at check out just pay five
dollar shipping
bluetooth.com order code frenemies to
receive your first month free
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
our frenemies podcast
okay do i need to tell you all about
quip again this is the company by the
way
pink and black i i don't remember but
you guys crushed it
on the last time when we did the
competition and trisha of course
won as i knew you would and everything
this feels like weird sexual
what's up we were talking about jousting
that's what we're doing but like
it's just stop it's not it's quick but
anyway
i love quit ethan and i are competing to
raise the most money for charity once
again depending depending on which sells
the most
so you can get rewards just by brushing
your teeth with the frenemies themed
electric toothbrushes
this toothbrush is insane i love it i'm
obsessed with oral hygiene
and i will never use another toothbrush
let me explain click it
it vibrates every dentist tells you
vibrating toothbrush give you the best
brush period period end of story
and it helps you get that perfect brush
because it times it 30 seconds
and then it goes wait wait and then you
go 30 seconds 30 seconds
you get the idea you get that perfect
brush so that you always know that
you're getting that two-minute dentist
recommended brush
bam slam damn and if you do the
two-minute brush you'll earn extra
rewards for that day
these points can be redeemed by rewards
you want like a target e gift card
or even a free quip brush refill
wow dud bruh whoa bruh it comes in
all pink or all black and has vibration
on two minute timer that pulses
everything i already said that i just
said that in great detail trisha i
literally just talked about that and
great now they can get them for ten
dollars off
yeah the smart electric toothbrush chat
with the code peace and love
they love and love they're fans of the
show i love that
at getquip.com get quipped.com called
peace and love and remember each
uh purchase is a ten dollar to a
non-profit charity that's amazing
i i correct me if i wrong but last i
heard they raised like ten thousand
dollars from you guys
oh my gosh that's amazing i know that is
correct uh i was like
whoa that was like a week after
the last time we did the ad so it's
probably significantly higher so i mean
shout out to quip i love quip yeah
that's amazing um so if you want to
support trisha's
uh a charity which is the national
center for transgender
equality or if you want to support mine
or if you just like black toothbrush is
better
you can tr uh mine goes to support the
trevor project
okay lgbtq plus month coming up so i was
already getting early on that yeah the
support of both yeah i i wanted to
support our trans and lgbt
the trevor project yeah it helps with
the job placement and then the trevor
project course uh
so who do you think will raise the most
money trisha obviously but get it go to
q not q t q
u i p dot com
y'all know how to spell it get quit calm
and use called peace and love to get 10
off all pink or all black smart brush
and quick will donate ten dollars of
each purchase so
that's get quipped.com with codepeace
and love terms of ply
we're back you know jason's probably
like is she really talking about me
again
like this like but he has a co okay
let's not talk about jason ash i was
just thinking like in his mind it's like
he should be thanking me we can you know
we get some good views on this podcast
no you're right welcome for the free
promotion trailer please pay
by the way trailer's suing me i'm like
excuse me do you want
nobody to watch your fights because i
was talking about it so much before
after enduring and these guys really
don't want any but they're really trying
to go bankrupt
because i'm not i'm not going to promote
their dumb ass [ __ ] fights anymore i
just promoted their show what if that
makes them millions of dollars
that's paying their legal fees for
against you jason nasho
whatever he's a public figure i can talk
about him what the hell okay no nobody
says you can't okay let's stop this
um mike okay so this is fun
by the way the the theme of this episode
is like uh
the dip the [ __ ] of youtube it's
like all the
all the um all the alpha males are
coming after us
the alpha brains why is it so yeah why
is there so much like
like frat boy energy on youtube right
now
i can't i've always hated frat boys and
the bravado of that whole
like uh alpha maleness yeah it's weird
and i and i just find myself always at
odds with these douchebags and like mike
and and face blanks are like the epitome
of like
alpha brain like oh hey bro i'm a
[ __ ] alpha
i'll be honest i didn't know the other
guy i know mike i didn't know the other
guy so i was like confused why all of a
sudden like he's involved in this like i
was so cuz i know
okay so i don't know who that is what it
is like you know i don't know
he's like best friends with keemstar and
they have a podcast called your mom's
basement and like so
obviously keemstar is like the biggest
piece of [ __ ] on the planet and just
really
like all around bad dude the one with
the tattoos has a podcast with keemstar
yeah facebook and how does mike tie into
it i think he's just a guest on the show
mike and in phase blanks are starting uh
like a house
right right okay yeah right i assume
they're friends but they're on this no
jumper podcast
right so anyway here's let's show the
clip before we get too heated
girls charlie the millions tick tockers
all those people
probably wake up in fear every day
trisha paytas and yeah
h3h3 klein yeah
imagine
so stupid that's what i'm joking about
charlie demilia wakes up
oh ether i'm so afraid
i feel like a big thing to note is the
tick tockers we talk about are
actual orthopedos
you know what i mean like orthopedics
what the f did you just say
orthopedophiles you know what i mean
like it's it's what is she saying
i don't understand like the james
charles the tony lopez
the andreas lopez they are all
p words orthopedo doctors we say that
now orthopedist
it's the way to like go around the word
but like
ortho means mouth
okay but orthopedo
once again ethan proving everyone right
that you are dumb anyways
we talk about time knowing that these
who are like sexting minor is like
what i mean well no he okay well hold on
he he's specifically mentioning like
demilio and
dixie that's who he's talking about i
mean i don't think i like bullying them
i was just like oh it's kind of weird
that you guys and then i was said sorry
right away when they hurt their feelings
like ever heard everyone talk about the
snails i'm like oh yeah they're kind of
bratty and then she treasures me i'm
like i'm sorry
dixie i'm not sorry about but charlie
i'm sorry yeah yeah yeah dick's dick
guys i i wake up in fear of trisha every
day
i think she's fine she's like 100
million on her video you know but like
i mean i was there i think what he's
worried about
is that mike is a giant pants [ __ ]
dumbass and face blanks is threatened by
my
fast intellect i think also no one's i
don't think anyone let me
let me play the clip let me play the
clip those young
girls charlie demilio's tick-tockers all
those people
probably wake up in fear every day
h3 cline do you know what i'm saying
like imagine like knowing that
they give us so much power we're so
powerful i don't think anyone is worried
about us i don't think he
wakes up like trisha paytas he's a
climbing tree
i just had a i just had a nightmare that
he mentioned me on the show
yeah let's keep watching i like that he
said my name right though he gave it he
did a pronunciation perfect oh yeah he
studied he studied the arts of squirting
i liked mike at one point i really liked
mike like i thought it was cool that he
talked about sobriety i read his book i
liked it i was like always really
supportive of him like i'm so confused
by all of this
i'm like he hates me because
everybody does all these bros i don't
hate you no not you i'm saying all these
frat boy dudes hate me because i always
[ __ ] on them
you're more of a feminist there's like
not an ounce of feminism in these guys
like they don't really get what 2021's
about what 2020 is about what women it's
like
feminism is about no i don't know i'm
not part of the boys club i just don't
care about their dumb [ __ ] like
cool guy party go [ __ ] chicks thing
like it's just i think they're i think
they're insecure little boys that are
trying to act tough because they're
little babies inside
just don't get the aggressiveness of
this like i saw it i was like this is
like a lot
like i get people having an opinion
there's a lot to hate me on but like the
the things they attacked us me us
whatever before i was like this is a
weird
bullies well here let me finish let me
finish
the horse i called him so sorry well
okay well well i mean hey is it bullying
if it's true i mean he is an old horse
her people hurt people i was just a
little hurt i'm sorry he's not he's not
an old horse he's an old man
okay come on let's watch the [ __ ]
clip please these people are
over their shoulders gunning dude like
just waiting for them to [ __ ] up
watching
every step they take you right now
that's gotta be a horrible feeling for
some of these [ __ ] kids dude oh my
god
hello they're like the biggest [ __ ]
influencers the world has ever known
they literally like that's literally how
being a celebrity works dumb [ __ ]
and i'm not even the one and we're just
having fun so [ __ ] you mike
yeah at least we wait till monday it's
part of me sometimes always once they go
off i'm like you know what i can just
hold myself right
it's not that important yeah at least we
wait till monday that's the best defense
ever
that's [ __ ] hilarious please
okay let's okay let's okay serenity now
no let's just practice let's just watch
the clip for the sake of the audience
and then let's comment okay is
bullying from the people who have
every reason to hate bullying listen
cause they're the people that were
bullied people
they're the people that were bullied
like trisha is was bullied
h3 are you going to try to tell me right
now a3 was the cool kid at his high
school
is that does what do you think more with
weather again that's like
he's like i was again this is the same
type of alpha [ __ ] that is just so
pathetic and insecure
he's like i was the cool kid at high
school unlike h3h3
he should be against bullying
i don't get it i mean yeah we're i
believe
what yeah but mike how old is mike what
okay again
and you'll you'll find that all these
frat boys are obsessed with high school
when they were cool
they're like i was so cool bro high
school was the best time of my life
at high school bro be afraid of people
who go high school was the best time of
my life
i was not i would i was do you know the
context of what this is brought up and
do we know where this even started like
why did this even
so weird doesn't matter i guess it
doesn't matter but not really but
isn't he kind of bullying me though at
the same time in his anti-bullying space
she is kind of bullying me i feel
bullied i want a bully right now i want
to bully him i feel like mike's
i feel like mike wants to throw me in a
trash can and call me a nerd
you know what i mean kind of doing that
right yeah he's like [ __ ]
nerd i'm gonna throw your ass in a trash
can [ __ ] if i was in high school i
would [ __ ]
kick your ass bro yeah
he probably does not watch one man punch
i would assume
one punch man one punch man yeah that's
why i love one punch man he's
he's the ultimate anti-bully is he i
don't know i just thought that was a
nerd thing that's what i think he kind
of is
the ultimate anti-bully really okay
cause he's like so powerful and he just
represents how
insecure i am and i just wish i was that
strong okay
can we get to anyway here thank you you
think he was
cleaning up out in there and [ __ ]
ohio universe and i don't think so right
now so he said wait let me go back sorry
i know bob we i know mike you sweet
sometimes the funniest thing you sweet
dumb soul
like don't try to be funny then you're
funnier and mike is when he doesn't do
that like delivering to camp whatever
he's doing
like you know we're digging mike you
sweet dumb soul
oh he really is just dumb and both of
these guys that's why i kind of feel bad
his brain is made of hot dog i think and
yeah i just you know i feel bad when he
like attacks them with like a lower
intellect because like their insults
like you know what i mean i don't know
i'm not smart i mean you're smarter than
them
but compared to like i'm smarter than
all both of them
they're like uh human popsicle they're
like flesh popsicles
they're just sacks of meat they're just
like
they're just like testosterone and like
i was cleaning up out and there and
[ __ ]
because i didn't get chicks are you
gonna try to tell me right now was the
cool kid at his high school
is that does what do you think laura
with weather you think he was you think
he was
cleaning up out in there and [ __ ]
ohio universe when he says cleaning up
he's saying
i didn't [ __ ] chicks and that's what
makes me not cool
oh agreed with him on this one
just kidding i'm people are like just
not doesn't back eat in the way no i
know you're kidding i'm kidding well i
don't care first of all
i don't judge people by how many people
they've slept with that's the that's one
of the things that these alpha [ __ ]
brains think is like
that's literally the times that i've had
like vicarious sex
when looking back on is the times where
i was the most
insecure and desperate to validate
myself right like
yeah and so like these guys i think
they're just they're so desperately out
of touch with their emotions and they're
like being a human being is that they
they
really value themselves by how many
women they slept with and i just find
that so
odd yeah there's a lot of small dick
energy coming from this
right and there's more there's more
asthmatic energy coming forward i
wouldn't shame people like that normally
but this is real small like energy the
way they talk about sex workers
me people like all this stuff so anyways
i'm sorry i'm trying okay we'll get to
you
i know you you're ready though hold me
back hold me back it's my turn to [ __ ]
on them call the nerd in high school
isn't like the worst
no but it's just it's the mentality he
wants to throw me in the dumpster and
steal my lunch money
i think i'm so blinded by what they said
about me that i'm like oh whatever ethan
got off easy by the way i was
kind of not i was like were you cleaning
up in high school
yeah i looked good i was a water polo
player right you were fit
yeah and i thought and then you know i i
had relationship i had relation sexual
relations in
college high school
no you'd have to be literally mental do
you understand to say high school was
the best part of my life and i wasn't
getting bullied i was getting [ __ ] by
my teachers mike so it was a little odd
you were getting bullied i was like oh
that's
so funny i'm pretty sure i was getting
molested and
r word by my teachers and the principal
didn't believe me and i hadn't
ever loved what a dumbass he is he's
like you were bullied you piece of [ __ ]
you had it coming
i didn't move school four times because
teachers were being inappropriate so
thank you for that mike's such a legend
yeah but did you [ __ ] chicks like mike i
gotta hear this take again people who
have every reason to hate [ __ ]
listen cause they're the people that
were bullied people they're the people
that were bullied like trisha is
was bullied what is he basing that off
of
because i'm fat i don't know what's it
[ __ ] i definitely was and i
definitely
i love i love how when it comes to me
he's like you know he was bullied but he
says it like a fact like trisha
she was bullied ethan come on you you
know he was probably bullied
i literally never said that ever though
and also just like
well don't only kill myself in 2005.
that's why my band is the most trauma in
my life because teachers wouldn't leave
me alone and they come to my house and
just our word
i just think i'm sorry that's so
traumatic but i think it's hilarious
that he calls that bowling
is that what he's referring to i don't
know what else it could be he doesn't
know
i think he's just so funny how off he is
okay go ahead mike go off quick go off
king walking
h3 are you going to try to tell me right
now h3 was the cool kid at his high
school
is that does what do you think laura
with weather you think he was you think
he was clean it didn't rape anyone if
that's what you mean i mean
yeah i would say three of the three guys
sitting at that table have allegations
against them
so i don't know how many you have but i
would say you're winning
okay he's like dude how many girls did
you even rape in high school
seriously they've all had some serious
oh
[ __ ] that's crazy cleaning up out and
they're in [ __ ] ohio universe
i don't think so right like these are
the people that should be standing up
and being like yo we're not gonna do
that
i think we literally do that with
everybody i think with
dave even jimmy fallon we called up like
you should have created david dobrik
we've called that james charles like we
literally say all the time like
because they're part of the frat the
fraternity of like don't ask don't tell
right but you set up for like we like
big nick like all these people that you
know
i've gotten people oh they like david
dobrik and they think we're doing him
dirty
so it's like by holding people
accountable he he said something like
jeff is taking over jeff whitaker and
i'm like this is the same guy that lied
about
not being there when he was obviously
exactly there and like [ __ ] on the rep
like jeff okay he's he's doing his part
to like make good
but like let's not forget that he was
the guy that literally told his fans to
go
to go harass the reporter right yeah
and like but so it's just like what and
like i feel like all
like the majority of the show especially
the second like the 2021 of this show
trying to like help people because
actually we can like people listen to us
so i was just like oh [ __ ] maybe we
should use this
for good and not go after people like
that don't like us cargo like no you're
my left and i'm not trying to come for
dixie for not eating snails you know
but i will start coming for like david
dobrik jason all these people that like
never
i've been doing this i haven't been held
accountable you know what i mean it's
not bullying it's called like
no we're and i'm sorry did we not raise
fifty thousand dollars for rain for
victims every day and i was like
i'm so sorry i donated ten thousand of
our own money yeah i was just like i'm
seeing so
yeah i'm just like so confused he is
so s he the problem is mike
is that now that you're out of high
school and you're a big boy
and i don't fit in the trash can or
locker anymore i'm way too fat good luck
picking us up yeah good luck good luck
fitting my fat ass in a locker is that
you don't get to be alpha on me
i am a even though i have a tiny jewish
[ __ ]
you said like five times today i think
it's so funny okay i say
oh my my new insult is mike why don't
you suck my tiny jewish dick
you know what else i don't like about
mike heath no good
i think it's funny mike thinks he looks
like you said it's new you've been
saying that on the show for like four
years
yeah okay fair enough new on this show
it's because they've tricked themselves
to believe that they're the do-gooders
they're the good guys and they're the
ones who like are protecting everybody
else it's
it's [ __ ] insane yeah because until
until
even started talking about david dobrik
everyone literally was like he's
amazing and now it's like all these
people have covered up
all this abuse and stuff that trauma
that he's done to girls and races and
all this stuff like that it's like
nobody even paid attention before and
like oh my god how dare we bring like
away
their entire argument is that we have
convinced ourselves that we're the
do-gooders
because but that's not true because one
time you made fun of dixie dimillio
that we're a bunch of frauds because
because i don't even i don't even say
we're do-gooders i just talk about i
never say that either
yeah it's like i know what like oh my
god i think you guys are douchebags
like i know nothing about you i think
this is the same is this the same guy
if trisha peyton says it then it's true
and it's like yeah yeah but no
what are you even talking i don't even
know you like if i if i could go off on
you but i have no idea i don't know
anything about you like i don't
know okay i'll tell you a little bit
about him he's like owner of phase which
is like the ultimate douche gamer
uh collective and he owned
he had recently admit to owning a
website called cs go wild
which is basically a gambling website
for kids where he and they're super
shady i don't know the details about his
gambling sites so i don't want to speak
out of school
but he but these websites i'm not i
don't know if his did or to what extent
but
uh they basically steal money from kids
oh [ __ ] yeah like i guess i guess i'll i
mean that's like
i don't know anything about that but i
guess that's my whole point too is like
i don't know this person like if i heard
something about you that was like
inappropriate like like that romeo
lacoste guy from the last episode
everyone know i'll just say his name
romeo
whatever like if there's like
inappropriate stuff with miners and like
it's proven and like people
like james charles and admitted to if
people mention i'll keep coming for you
i don't know anything about you i'm not
gonna come for you because i know
nothing about you you haven't done that
stuff but if you're you know if you're
doing something inappropriate minor is
all no
then i'll come for you but there's
nothing come for you for so why are you
even in this conversation
no we don't even claim to be do-gooders
i always say all the time [ __ ]
i say all the time i'm a hooker i'm fat
whatever you want to say about me like
it's
we're just having fun you dip [ __ ]
tiny little [ __ ]
same definition impulsive when she's not
on anymore like got fired whatever like
like you guys are bullies then because
you guys talk about people like what the
hell are you talking about
no they're literally they're scared
they're scared
the truth is that all these guys are
scared of us because they all have
allegations against them
and they're super scared that we're
gonna [ __ ] talk about them stop doing
inappropriate [ __ ] with people
i know it's like bill gates now yeah bro
it's like bill gates and i was in
headlines for like being
for [ __ ] around with women i'm like
bill
he's got that money who would [ __ ] bill
gates i know it's like a joke but like
can you imagine like straddling
gates oh baby he smells like yoda he
probably pays good
but he's like such a weird guy
yeah he was a part of pizzagate i don't
even know what that is
that was a [ __ ] thing pizzagate yes
i literally don't know what it is okay
so that's not real for the right
pizza
i got really round i haven't riled in a
while i don't know why i love about this
i'm just really i saw this friday i was
like well here they didn't even mention
you specifically let's keep going
i love i like i have a lot of love
tricia i really do think she's a good
person i don't know ethan but you [ __ ]
her
you [ __ ] her she ate pizza hey you
guys shouldn't be bowling people
you [ __ ] her
was like triggered for a number of
reasons not even in a bad way not like
it took me back but i was just like
in the same sentence that you're like
they're bowling they think they're
do-gooders and as soon as he says
oh yeah i like trisha and they're like
oh you [ __ ] her like he didn't even
say anything about it he just said she's
a good person and then they brought up
like you [ __ ] her you should
buy but by the way the one person that
actually knows you in that room
right says he likes you you're a good
person and they're like well you [ __ ]
her it's like
okay let's not listen to the guy that
actually knows you it's like
you dated like lana rose and no one's
like shaving you for that like but
that's
like mike secretly hates women he'll say
like no no like i dated a sex worker but
like he hates her because he
disrespected her on no more times by
cheating on her the girl that he cheated
on with is ava louise girl he called her
a gremlin
it's like you [ __ ] her up i hate i
hate go the [ __ ] off guys [ __ ] girls and
because they got caught or whatever then
they call the the girl the gremlin and
stuff like that like oh
she was gonna have to suck your dick
like what are you talking mike is such a
woman hater and he hates
workers by lana he's cheated on her
he like publicly admitted to it in a
game saying he got head from people like
he's
so he oh you know virtual reality
has to get head from somebody over in
[ __ ] florida wherever
they are and thinking that's cool like
oh yeah baby give me like
you are such a loser you're [ __ ] up
like perfect examples of all the energy
that you
need a virtual person to suck your dick
you psychopath
you [ __ ] up psycho
[Applause]
logan paul dumped you means you're a
psychopath the biggest sociopath on the
internet dumps you you're a psychopath
you're a dirty stuff
psychopath that doesn't deserve anything
that doesn't deserve any sort of clown
michael
the fact that george junko is on the
podcast and not you means you are just
the scum of the internet nobody wants to
[ __ ] with you
you know like love that don't want to
what by the way he is kind of the
ultimate loser right now like he took
the l from lana
and logan the same week and his face
looks like a ball sack
there you said it i'm a bully [ __ ]
who's the bully now
i'm ready be scared all my followers are
going to come attack you mike he's going
to start waking up in a cold sweat oh
christopher peterson's going to mention
me on the friend of me oh my god
just like dixie live in fear young
michael
god mike is so annoying your book is
good bro like by the way
about hating sex workers and being a
womanizer one of the things alana said
when she dumped him is that he was
mad that she didn't want to have a
threesome with him like oh she's a porn
star so she's supposed to
to do any sexual thing you want like oh
that pros and cons
you know what i'm saying oh we're
getting for that oh my god yeah this is
the roast
mike show trust me we're commenting
that's what i'm saying this is like the
frat boys like
the [ __ ] alpha brains of youtube my
thing is like they're so dumb they
probably just were like you know wow
this will get them riled up we'll get
talked about because nobody cares about
them they're aging people starting a
hype house or whatever the [ __ ] at 30.
dude
can you oh yeah wait hold his face blank
send mike i looked it up and how it
would
be eight dude he's thirty three six
thirty six three six yeah thirty six
ah you're starting a content house at
thirty yeah
like
my mind he's trying to be a creeper he
compares himself to jason at the end of
this and you are going down that same
path except more irrelevant
because nobody cares about him and he's
starting a hype out content house
he doesn't want to live with logan or
his girlfriend because he has to start a
he even said in the same interview he
goes i'm just trying to create content
with girls that's my work that's my
thing it's like nobody
likes you you're logan paul sidekick
look what happened to jason ness that's
your future baby that is where you're at
you're creepy stop hanging out with
underage people
talking about throwing me in a locker
joke's on you [ __ ]
look how thick my ass is locker
definitely maximum of six inches
yeah show it good luck hey mike throw
this in a locker okay
mike throw this in a locker oh no way
bro
locker six inches max no way she's
fitting in there buddy
you think he could stuff you in a locker
let's try maybe with his feet maybe with
his feet like
get in there [ __ ] oh my god
okay that's what mike would say i'm
gonna get the ac i'm like dying oh my
god i'm just getting so riled up
thank you moses oh he's 35
it is this is insane this is so
insane it's the crazy thing i've ever
heard of dude he's so delusional
he literally got famous for making a
podcast with logan paul and now he
thinks he's like some big shot
and he's making oh it's gross he thinks
he made it he thinks he's made it he's
just like you know
anyway let's go back because this is too
good it's [ __ ] insane
it's insane yeah it's insane like i have
a lot of tricia i really do think she's
a good person i don't know ethan but
[ __ ] her
they're all like
i was i was like is this like in 2004 or
like what the hell like so [ __ ] weird
like you dated a porn star like everyone
has and only fans like what the [ __ ]
like his wife was there
yeah like yeah i know right okay let's
let's get let's
we're never gonna make our way through
this video you [ __ ] you she ate pizza
off your dick i need to like put it i
need to put something yeah he knows her
really well
he can vouch for her character better
than you a wall that acknowledges that i
did that like
just a picture really i watched it i had
to see it with my own two eyes
i had to i watched it for [ __ ] two
seconds it lasted about two seconds
i just had to [ __ ] say i think that
was
yeah i think we made like like almost a
million dollars in like a week
and i still that's still my number one
video i don't have to do anything on
only fans now and i still make six
figures from that one video so
amazing more people try and find it the
pornhub can't show it anymore so now
they come and try and buy it for me or
elena or whatever
and i still make like a couple hundred
thousand dollars a month off of it so
are you
serious yeah it's my biggest one and i
had to do it one time and i honestly i
didn't care i wanted to do it they were
my friends like at the time i was like
single and i was just like whatever like
who cares
that's amazing dude moses you better get
moses you better get your dick out for
seven figures he won't
no i'm kidding i'm just kidding no god
please god don't
please god for we can still go buy my
old
content on my office be you know support
us we're getting a second house with
that money you know what i mean
we're getting a vacation we're getting a
vacation home and it was right down the
street for some reason
yeah we are people love that i'm getting
a lake home pro
lake front property in the in the same
company i don't want up that we're
actually going to get a second house in
the same community we're in in the same
gated community we're in
that's what you said last time no
there's a lake away from us like five
minutes from us and then there's in the
same gated community we're gonna get
another house we're gonna get three with
that
only fans money thank you adam and lena
and i hope they they flourish too you
know what i mean
but like the fact that they're so i
don't know if they're like bitter or
that we're making money off of doing
this or like what like what
i'm so they're just they really do and i
hate to say this
they hate they don't respect women and i
and i don't say that lightly because
just again fast forward to uh mike being
like
ethan barely got any [ __ ] in college as
like the ultimate insult to like oh my
god you [ __ ] yourself
yeah i mean and face banks backing them
up all the way
nobody wants to [ __ ] you guys except for
the fact that you have money right now
and some clouds so you're going to find
these little young girls but you are not
going to engage
here you will never be in a fulfilling
loving relationship because you are
deeply damaged and so insecure
and you are so possessed with this idea
of masculinity that is literally
poisoning your heart and minded soul
and you will never find love and true
companionship in life
the proudest moment i've had of you
right there that was good i love that oh
do you want to yeah i mean you would do
like that yeah
the album was weird oh
true masculinity is being in touch with
your i you know what there's no such
thing as true masculinity that's another
low hanging fruit thing like
sex workers fatness like you know
there's like other things to come for me
for you know what i mean i mean
literally if you go to my only fans you
can come for me for five dollars
hey nice plug i showed it on my
instagram because i never promote and i
don't even promote my only fans anymore
i never promote it i love when you
promote your own friends i'm proud of
you thank you i but i don't even need to
promote anymore people just go i haven't
played
42 000 followers i saw a post about that
i was like damn i just gave me a minute
to flex and i was just like
paid on there top point zero one percent
and i'm just like selling like old
content
so you dumb [ __ ]
i cannot stand mike now and i don't know
and i don't even don't even know that
guy he's just so pointless he has no
he has no r he just has no reason to
exist on the internet like he's so
that's why i call him
yeah literally yeah cause his mind is
blank thank you
thank you so much hit him with the sound
bite
i know i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
kidding
let's continue because this whole thing
is gold i didn't realize we would get
squeezed
like a [ __ ] juicy lemon well it was a
slow news day that's why we're talking
about this otherwise
i have plenty of stuff excuse me slow
news day for who i was just like you
know what they're so stupid and they're
so misogynistic and so far [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] like that i'm like okay this
is like a
you know what i mean because if you have
an opinion they have an opinion like
there's there's people like oh we hate
whatever he's got his phone open what
are you looking at freak
for having a phone well he's got a phone
with the hammock
space he might have a phone well he's
got an image open i want to see what it
is like he has an image open no it's a
yeah oh it's free oh it's his phone case
okay
mike's such a freak why does he have a
phone okay all right let's continue
so does trisha no that's no not your
girl i was asking oh trisha i'm pretty
sure church is jake garcia gone there as
well yeah
although she's in a relationship i
wonder how that has changed [ __ ] she
still fires shots at that
jason nash so he said all the time she
goes is she big on only fans and then
the guy next to him the little oh i
missed that way let me go back let me go
back oh she's big in more ways than one
oh let me go back
really sure what does she clean up in
the
adult space of course she does she must
so does trisha
no that's no not your girl i was asking
oh trisha i'm pretty sure church is
gigantic on there as well yeah
although she's in a relationship i
wonder how that has changed
she is big in more ways than one
hilarious
yeah also people were just like he got
baited out
bro you're such a beta bank she got
baited out of that conversation
literally nobody listens to beta banks
oh
is that a good is that a better do you
like beta banks dan
i like the blanks better you like
facebook because i feel like he'll take
the beta will insult him more that means
oh like alpha male 1 beta male i think
of like testing like beta testing
oh it's hard but like so these guys
would all consider themselves alva males
probably at least for sure banks
and mike that means like i'm the alpha
male and beta males are like little they
would probably consider me a beta
okay beta which is like a little [ __ ]
boy i like a little better in my life
well whatever i think the whole alpha
baited thing is stupid but i'm more of
an
omega man myself what was that called
dan
no not omega are you talking about the
one that's out that's yeah
that's sigma male i'm a sigma male yeah
sigma male 1
anyway stupid i think beta banks is
pretty funny just because i think it
would insult him more
like so weird just such a random insult
to throw out there like
there's look at so many things insult me
for but like she's big in more ways than
one like
you jeff but you just called us bullies
you literally just called us bullies
and then called her fat for no reason
and by the way
baby fat needs to be gone real soon
you're 29 you shouldn't be by the way
hanging on your cheeks
and we're gonna talk about fat and
you've never even that to a fatty one
and you've never even said anything
about him god i still don't know like
right out the gates to call you fat i
mean hello
there's nothing i can say about him he's
so boring he adds nothing people over
talk him like there's nothing
so i think phase blinks is good i think
just that person next to mike is fine
too the person next to mike i think
that's fine
that's pretty good trish is out here
watch the [ __ ] she still
fire shots at that oh he knew he [ __ ]
up you see his face little beta banks
was like nobody heard me
although i wonder how that she changed
exactly she's still
[ __ ] up beta banks had a beta moment
yeah
can you i can't zoom on his face i don't
know why
but just look at beta bank's face right
here here can you zoom dan
i don't let me zoom this is important
no no no no this is important to capture
the betterness of this moment
the blankness dan's working on zooming
here we go okay we have to capture this
moment this is important
i have no issues with the guy next to
mike adam you're cool
mike you're a piece of [ __ ]
dan is crunching the numbers we are
but i don't i'm supposed to be able to
zoom on the apple fine we don't need to
zoom in on that face
um trisha you know what it turned me
into mean i was in such a good mood now
i feel like i want to be a bully like i
want to bully these people these are the
people that bully me and i get to bully
them back right now okay let's just
watch his face one more time
everybody focus on faze blank's face and
his debate a moment no that's no not
your girl i was asking oh trisha i'm
pretty sure church is gigantic on there
as well yeah
although she's in a relationship i
wonder how that has changed [ __ ] she's
still
fire shot yes
do you not love that so weird it's just
so damn back me up that was amazing
he goes yeah he literally went
he literally went ooh but nobody
listened to him he went ooh
come on that's all my whole life is
nobody listening to him that's probably
just him being talked over if he's
friends with all these people like he's
phased mommy and daddy didn't love me
like no i've been on the internet so
long and i know the most obscure people
i know nikki philippi
but i still never heard of this person
like that's how like he's invisible
stays invisible yeah he must be very
niche or something niche i don't know he
must be very niche because i really
don't know him
other than the fact he like i also heard
there was like allegations that he like
assaulted jake paul's assistant or
something oh he has
yeah he did phase has been in all kinds
why don't we get that rage under control
anger man
mommy you left me
the [ __ ] that's a john lennon song mom
you left me but i didn't left the video
my mom left him
well i feel bad if his mom left i don't
know anything about his personal life
feel bad
i'm sorry yeah i'm i am bullying him
face phase little baby boy we love face
jason nash guy
all the time really like is that what is
that can i just reflect on the fact
we've been talking about this clip for
like an hour
i mean that's what i'm saying what else
is there talking about because you're
staying for
the rest of my life like like 2047
is like [ __ ] mike and his dumb
wheelchair
2047. nobody's gonna care about whatever
like uh
mike was like i like jason i don't know
anything about him i don't know i don't
watch his videos but i'm like
just watch it we'll fire shots at that
jason nash guy
all the time really so what is that is
that what i stand for for the rest of my
life like
like 2047 is like i feel like mike's
just regurgitating like all of the
typical
like people all the bros that don't like
you it's like right
he doesn't know anything right literally
not and i also kind of love that he like
low-key stands me that he knows that i
talk about jason yeah and my last name
it's like hello open your church he has
a trisha folder on his desktop
i don't know mike's kind of
yeah that was the other one that said he
watched my only fans i don't know
okay mike okay taking his dumb
wheelchair
yeah honestly he never did anything
wrong i'm not i don't know the back
story he's never not talking about any
of his opinions or anything like that
i'm talking about i don't really watch a
ton of their videos but that group of
people like
seems to be very like i don't [ __ ]
know i'm not there i'm not
gonna touch my guy's my guys i don't
know anything about his opinions i don't
know anything about that group i'm like
he just has that to be like again just
so
stupid you're so dumb you just know that
i don't like him so you're like oh
just now you know anything about this
guy but i like him no but faze blinks
he's so insecure
the minute he goes i like them and then
he goes oh no no no no
oh i don't know but i don't want to
commit to that ah commit like
it or not commit or get off the pot you
know i'm like um
right commit or get off the pot
well why don't you just say [ __ ] commit
or get off the bus i'm sorry i do have i
do have some issues in my brain
that like triggers me into wait where's
the one anyway on that on the same
episode faze blanks
says well here just watch this i i love
this clip this is from the same episode
i think he's [ __ ] stupid
oh it is it okay i'm sorry
this is not from the is a different
podcast of him and keemstar
and uh he's responding to me making fun
of him and calling him faze blanks
okay he didn't like this he did not like
that nickname it does face clawn on
there though glam
clown face clam what is that it's face
clan
i thought it was banks phase banks so
the clan
he's a member of the clan i don't know
if you want to be a member of the clan
i don't want to have right i don't good
call
why do they call it that right because
they're dumb it's a game
well no a gaming clan is a is a common
uh i think he's a grand wizard of faze
clan
oh my god yikes
all right so listen to him i think he's
[ __ ] stupid to be honest and it's
funny because he refers to me as
face blanks says i'm dumb um
h3 if you're listening to this i'm
infinitely smarter than you
and um infinitely more successful than
you and i don't have to make [ __ ]
dumb youtube videos with you know
cosplaying with trisha paytas and
punch it down about every other creator
i'm not gonna lie i would love to see
you cosplay with trisha payta
yeah well keemstar would like to see you
in anything
wait why you gotta throw that in there
we love dressing up okay
it's something that i do that makes me
like childhood drama because i didn't
get to dress up
focuses on the fact that he said he's
infinitely smarter than me
how do you measure that exactly i made
these jokes on after dark so i know
people get
mad but let me crunch the numbers for
you phase blanks the only
iq number more different than mine would
be zero
right that's the only infinite
difference therefore i am infinitely
smarter than phase blanks
checkmate he has a zero iq right dan i
don't know if that made any sense
zero is infinitely different
than whatever my iq it was probably like
80. what 75.
you don't want me to with you i'm not
part of this i didn't call him dumb well
now i am
now you're dumb as [ __ ] because of what
you're talking about you're probably
infinitely
different yes zero zero is infinitely
different than any number right
the difference is it's undefined i'm
trying to make a
dude it's a well-known scientific
principle that zero and
infinity is a is kind of a close uh a
kind of an equivalent approximation of
things right
you have infinite nothingness and you
have infinite somethingness
therefore my iq is infinitely higher
than phase blanks
because he says he's infinitely smarter
than me that means that it has to have a
zero iq
i have like a 60 to 50 iq therefore i'm
infinitely smarter
okay nobody backed me up on this i have
to take your word for it i guess
maybe a 40 i don't i don't have a high
enough iq to follow
follow the math that you just laid out
there um and also i never said anything
about him not being successful so
oh insecure much i think yeah i think
he's got some
issues and i [ __ ] and i [ __ ] way more
chicks than you two by the way
uh yeah i mean yikes but also
us dressing in cosplay is the least
problematic thing that we do
like what yeah i don't know why he's so
mad it's because we're having fun
finally found a friend that wants to
please him with me and the fun
police the phase cl kkk cosplayers
had their childhood taken away from them
when they couldn't dress up and be like
a little kid yeah i enjoyed to do it now
like bullying bullying yeah bully
hey hey face hey phase uh
beta beta blanks you wanna go burn
across with me
or not with me i mean sorry hey face kkk
clan
you want to go burn across i'll call the
police i won't be there plan
um yeah i feel like i've been very
triggered i'm sorry i apologize for
calling people a horse
i don't apologize for calling my dumb
but
so no apologies to them i guess well i'm
not
i'm not a paul i i'm not paul i make no
apologies
right unless it's innocent unless it's
in a settlement agreement
you're to make an apology in for a
settlement i'm just don't back down
i'm just i don't know maybe you should i
don't know i don't don't listen to me
i'm just kidding i don't have advice for
this just a joke just a joke
yes
you got it so going down this thread of
mike being a
a giant douche uh lana you know
she's like the world's most famous porn
star she's got to be right
you know i i honestly haven't i never
heard of her before mike but really
i don't i mean she's like number one on
porn i thought riley reed was i like new
o'reilly reed
i always i think lana i think lana
dethroned her
okay but anyway we live we stand i don't
know much about lana so
she seems fine i mean i you know i have
no problem
yeah but anyway she's started leaking
all these dms of his yeah yeah
and it's so [ __ ] awesome he's
literally
sent her a pros and cons
it wasn't a joke he clarified on the on
the no jumper podcast he was like oh no
like
i thought maybe it would help her like
if we could salvage this relationship
what she's doing wrong in it i was like
now first of all if you want to know
what a baby what a little boy
um 35 by the way i'm 35 but i'm just
saying like i have a
like i mean it's time to grow up money
are you giving she bought she bought a
house
yeah for them to live in and he said he
was gonna move in with her
twice twice and then when the date comes
when he's supposed to move and he goes
baby
i'm moving in with faze blanks to make a
content house
maybe there's something more deep rooted
there that he's not out with yet you
know i don't know but i think they're
together i don't know because they were
really hardcore being like you wouldn't
do that i know you want to do and i'm
like you know i don't know i don't know
i don't want to out anyone i don't know
what i'm saying like you think face and
and mike are homeless
we make this dick homie they're they're
like
hatred towards women and stuff like that
you know i know people who didn't come
out until later in life and they
they hated women they had such hatred
towards like women and like that kind of
do you think they share one bedroom at
the at the house no but that would
explain like this aggression
like all this stuff too is like you know
i don't know it's a theory it's a
working theory
if this is a real thing that they're
gonna really i don't know i don't want
to lose bottles
no i don't know um i maybe think they're
working through this i think
we have a lot of issues beyond like in
all seriousness i got triggered it was
mean but
i maybe they're working through
something because honestly this is like
weird behavior working through something
the man is 35.
a lot of people don't like know
themselves or come out or come to terms
with their truth until they're 40.
i've been with someone that didn't come
to truth with themselves till they were
40.
what was this kind of aggressive
behavior towards women that
like was a red flag i think they just i
think they probably have issues with
their mom or something and that's why
they hate women that's usually what it
is
you know anyway here's the pros and cons
he literally sent this to her after she
dumped him right she dumped his ass for
being a child she dumped her on that
episode on no jumper
yeah he's a [ __ ] liar he also said
logan didn't fire him so
pros versus cons imagine you didn't want
to move to a floating island or
something
stupid okay pros vs cons why i date
you you're the prettiest girl on earth
hands down again
such a meathead he thinks that that's
the biggest compliment you can pay a
girl prettiest girl
yeah that's why i date you yeah
literally for your looks only
extremely loyal hardworking and
successful
wild sex appeal okay i mean you already
said she was pretty that's the pros
caring and attentive when i'm down
and out i feel compelled to save you
from how the world sees
has seen you in the past uh i don't
think she needs a [ __ ]
yeah he wants to save hers is that
he is compelled to save her that he is
the white
he's a white knight the pro jesus the
bro i'm a white knight
well she actually had a really funny
comment about it she said
she said she said he sent me a list of
pros and cons and most of it was just an
insult i mean literally like
a girl is like out of porn that doesn't
want to be involved with porn wild sex
appeal it's like okay
this is like the most embarrassing thing
i've seen man
i feel compelled to save you from how
the world sees you i think she has a
good reputation i see people
being like she's so sweet yeah i feel
like and guys and i see people actually
respecting her being like she's the
ultimate baddie
yeah like [ __ ] up i don't think anyone
is like shaming her for anything i'm
pretty sure you need saving more than
her
the fact that you think she needs saving
it's like why like it's so weird
shared love of travel food experience oh
you love to travel that's so interesting
of you mike
he loves to travel and he loves food
that's so interesting
nobody likes to travel or eat literally
nobody else other than the mic loves
that
so interesting pretty solid taste in
music decent
not that good i can't believe this is
not a joke like it seems like a parody
it reads like a parody like decent like
you know but like
this is real he said he's like here's
the only thing i can think to justify
dating you
pretty good taste of music decent
always have my back she sounds like a
[ __ ] badass girlfriend i know
like loyal he's like super loyal
nurturing successful always has my back
okay always right back is kind of just
the same as the loyalty yo
and then the next one is i can use you
good for my business networking see
caveat
holy [ __ ] bro you review she's crazy
okay now here's the deal breakers why
don't
you why i don't date you major deal
breaker that acquires deep and radical
change
mike you are not that [ __ ] big of a
deal yeah you're definitely not you're
not logan ball like damn
okay so now that looking a big deal you
know
we don't know he's he's literally nobody
save the turtles he's literally a nobody
right
that she for whatever reason he's like
the dude from that like the
fairy tale once where there's like a
show on netflix like the baker and the
superstar
he's the baker it's like this badass
superstar
is attracted to you for some reason that
nobody [ __ ] understands
and you're sending her do's and don'ts
okay so here we go she says he says
she's sickly obsessed with social
normalities
uh she's a porn star dude
even though everything your life is
about is outside the box then shaming
for my liberal thinking and approach to
life
another layer of hypocrisy literally so
unspecific she wants to be like
married and stuff like that's her thing
she wants to be married and have a
relationship and he just wants to have
three sums
yeah exactly exactly
he's like girl you are so obsessed with
social normalities i'm a 35 year old man
trying to move in with phase blanks and
start out eyeballs
probably is what he's referring to there
yeah yeah that's exactly what i mean
yeah dude literally literally try to
find
a self-respecting woman in this world
that is okay with that
yeah that is the most embarrassing thing
like if you're 20
yeah like jake paul uh content houses
team 10 i get it right
i get it who are you gonna recruit to be
in that house
30 and 35 years old are you gonna like
nobody's gonna come live in your
content house except like 18 year olds
yeah like yikes because anyone with
anything going on in their life
at all is not gonna live there
including you i would think this is
weird okay here we go
extremely needy when it comes to time
together i'm sorry
that sounds like a good thing yeah be
here at nine or don't come at all it
sounds like your ass is always [ __ ]
flaky
yeah and unwilling to accommodate to
make those times happen
come to my house i'm not coming there i
don't want to see anyone it has to be
just me
and us yeah because you're always trying
to vlog everything she actually just
wants to spend
she sounds like a really good girlfriend
trying to be like cloudy or yeah
with like all your friends and [ __ ]
she's like come spend quality time with
me and he shows up with like
like all of his homies and a camera in
her face me in the hospital with jason
david and jeff whitake when i overdose
yeah i was like oh okay everyone's here
yeah exactly so i was like you know how
it is when you're filming with david
like you just kind of have to come along
it would have taken more time to drop me
off at home like
that's why you were at the hospital
whenever anyways sorry it does kind of
give me a little ptsd in that same kind
yes no it is it's the whole right yeah
i don't want to see any anyone it has to
be just
us or leave me alone bro you are so
thick [ __ ] headed the girl wants to
spend quality time with you that's a
good
thing that's a good thing she actually
likes being with you
which is probably something that nobody
else in your life can actually say and
up until this point she never said
anything bad about mike he made like a
breakup video about it he cheated on her
like
all this [ __ ] and she was like so he he
streamed and recorded her conversation
the [ __ ] she's he continues and
relatively unwilling to get involved
with activities you know i like
the gym bro go [ __ ] into the gym on your
own time
cycling fit and tiny and like perfect
and other things i like to do which i
would have been more interested in doing
together
dude again seriously don't want a girl
to come to the gym and do everything
with them like
have some no he's contradicting himself
he's saying i don't want to spend
time with you but i'm also mad that you
won't come to the gym with me
it's like she can only exist and things
he can only make time for her
in activities she's already doing anyway
if he cannot make her feel any less
special i really wish she would
release more of this that's so good okay
those are the big issues here's the
minor issues so
these we can look over bro
did he really write this chewing with
mouth fully open
making slop noises almost on purpose
when i've told you a thousand times how
disgusting it is plus numerous other
social faux pas you are a walking faux
pas
you are a human faux pas oh my god
this guy is disgusting i've seen he
wrote the burgers the way he is
you are so i this has to be a joke like
this guy is disgusting in every aspect
of his life the way he eats when he
talks about all this stuff like that
like
what are you talking about the fact that
you wrote this to your girlfriend
somebody she said that he still deeply
cares about like that's so
insulting and so stupid and not even
worth men like what the [ __ ] that's how
she like how she eats
how much oh i can't girl baby
baby it'll never work you two with your
mouth open
when i told you a thousand times how
disgusting it is oh my god
plus numerous other shows oh my god this
i've seen them both yeah and then
she said there's a whole paragraph about
him being upset about me not wanting to
do a three-way with
i want to read that i know i want so i
want the rest so bad
ew ew grown men like that that need
three ways has so that's the small dick
and i don't know but it's about but
they're gonna
prove that they can be with two girls
that one like especially when the girls
don't want to do it
but also it's it's the it's the
expectation of him not respecting
like you're a porn star you do this for
film you
i'm entitled to do it with you at home
oh my god like this is so parallel to
like
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] i've gone through
and it's just like so like how are there
people like this like i literally
thought like there was only one but
that's one of the best things i've read
in a long time i have to say
wow she deleted them
i guess she felt bad but hey we're here
you shouldn't oh my god that was
literally so disrespectful even
privately
like that's so oh do we have the rest of
it no [ __ ]
i actually i actually based on his list
of cons i actually have a lot of respect
for and she sounds like a really good
girlfriend yeah of course like a lot
really loving good
yeah personally i don't really know much
about her i've seen her on stuff and she
seems like nice quiet doesn't care about
being in the box like doesn't even want
to be in the vlog kind of just does it
for him like you know what i mean
but i just i love that his list of
complaints actually managed to paint her
as like a good person
yeah no he has deep rooted issues with
like women or something i don't know he
has like this really
weird hatred towards like people and
women and
oh this is another thing she's weighted
just i don't know kind of fun
just while we're sitting on mike and
standing lana
i'm going to say this once for all my
beef with mike is deeper than the pros
and cons list
we had we had an agreement to be honest
if we were sleeping with other people
he lied and i found a used condom in his
garbage the day i came over
after wig brunch he told me
used it to jerk off and then later
admitted he did cheat on him
he said yeah adam confronted him on the
interview too and
it's like what like dude you're so
pathetic to jesus
you are literally the dumbest person
alive like i mean nobody should
i don't think you're lovable all i
remember is cheating and then going on
impulsive and [ __ ] on that girl for
an hour saying she's disgusting she's a
troll all this stuff like that it's like
that's so [ __ ] gross to do that like
if you're the one who slept
like had sex with her like you nasty
prick so continue because i didn't like
the idea of us being with other people
we agreed to discuss getting back
together when i turned from new york
city and after that conversation he
ignored me for multiple days hung out
with his ex-fuck buddy
and kept pursuing other women very
publicly i blocked him and moved on
and he had the audacity to send me five
pages of mostly insults
blaming me for the faults in the
relationship it sent me i've kept my
mouth shut through this whole thing
the initial reason we broke up was
because he said he was going to move in
with uh faizy faze kkk
or sorry faze grand wizard
face clan grand wizard he said he was
going to move in with me finally and
then the next day he said he would be
moving with phase blanks
instead his first youtube title after we
broke up was literally i'm moving in
with summer rey
i've been continuously disrespected
publicly by him and after the break
have said nothing i hate this term
because we will overuse it but he's
super gaslighting with her too she'll
like
for sure reported conversation he's like
she's fake with you guys right now this
is all fake she's this is not how she
talks like you could tell
you could tell in the pros and cons it's
all gas lighting because he's trying to
list
things that are bad that are actually
good traits of her trying to be a good
girlfriend
right like you wanting to spend quality
time with me without cameras and people
there
con right and also just making her feel
bad for like the way you eat like stuff
that
will make a girl like go nuts you know
like thinking about that [ __ ] it's like
oh well
it's just and you know what that part by
the way when he wrote about her eating
habits that came at the end of a very
long thoughtful note that was something
that he thought about yeah
and he was like that i want to
definitely include to her
and i want to see the three-way thing
you [ __ ] gross pig
well so there you have it that's uh mike
matt i still don't want to say his name
i'm sorry
oh mela oh thank you i think i always
call him magilic but
i think it is maylac yeah i
i think it pronunciation you don't have
chrissy teigen on your notes i wanted to
talk about her but that's fine
well uh talk about the same people which
is why we can talk about them no
i i wasn't chrissy tegan i would i just
didn't item not super
she was like us mega bully it's like
no but beyonce she was like really
telling a girl to like kill courtney
do you remember courtney she was on my
old podcast that got cancelled but she
was on my uh earth day i'm sorry
uh courtney's not non-binary now um they
were on my podcast and they recently
revealed like i guess chrissy teigen
um bullied like this person like to the
point of like saying like kill yourself
like take a dirt nap but not only snap
not
so vocal but like privately would dm
courtney
like kill yourself and then lindsay
lohan too there's tweets now saying to
like lindsay lohan that she wants that
uh chrissy wanted once he did like kill
herself and i was just like
how is this person not cancelled like
chrissy tegan right john legend all
stuff like that it's like and she's in
target and also it's like how is this
person not canceled for like telling
someone to like actually kill themselves
i think it just came out
but when i read those and people go oh
it was 10 years ago i'm like
that violinist is kind of unforgivable
but that yeah that's like telling
someone like
kill them that's like next level yeah i
mean there's only like one person that
comes to mind that like said that
and in a direct message not like a tweet
right like yeah like specifically going
to them in a direct message where they
only they can see it
repeatedly repeatedly she was she famous
at the time courtney was 16 she was a
minor that married a 50 year old and
anyone in that situation knows it's
a 50 year old how did you blame him like
wait wait was chrissy teigen famous at
the time she sent those
um yeah yeah yeah it was yeah it was
yeah because she was like a model and
stuff like that yeah and
i mean failed i thought people liked her
she flopped modeling you flop as a
personality and now you're flopping out
of target cancel her
i just really wish people would cancel
like give the same energy towards like
females doing this [ __ ] than
like just the guys i mean there's a lot
of guys that do [ __ ] but like
i think she's married to john legend
that she has status that i was just like
damn and she just didn't a half-ass
apology which by the way she had
courtney blocked she said she said
that oh i'm like apologize to courtney
and i want to reach out to them you know
publicly but like courtney's like
this [ __ ] has been blocked let me see
the apology
here let me uh ian can you set that up i
just need some more to talk about
because i was just like really i was
really upset by it i was just like
damn like i think she'll get i think
she'll that story is so vile i think it
will catch up i think that's like
there's a lot of things you can
apologize
for i feel like this is way too little
and also something that you can't come
back where you tell them to kill
themselves
in a private dm like no yeah crazy
that's crazy
that's not like that's unless she was
like 16 i could forgive her at the time
maybe no no she was an adult yeah this
was in 2012
christie tegan is 35 right now so she
would have been what uh
i mean it's nine years ago so she was
like 26
that's um yeah i mean i don't think i've
ever told anyone to kill themselves ever
at any age 26 is old enough to know not
to
do that i mean that's that's that's
psycho here she apologized on twitter
not a lot of people are lucky enough to
be held accountable for all their past
[ __ ] in front of the entire world oh
that's like passive aggressive
not enough people are lucky to be held
for all their [ __ ] entirely from the
world
i'm mortified and sad at who i used to
be i was an insecure attention seeking
control i'm ashamed and completely
embarrassed at my behavior
but that is nothing compared to how i
make courtney feel i have worked so hard
to
give you guys joy and be beloved and the
feeling of letting you down
is nearly unbearable truly these were
not
my only mistakes and surely won't be my
last as hard as i try but god i will try
they're not mistaken i have tried to
connect with courtney privately but
since i publicly fueled all this i want
to also publicly apologize
i'm so sorry courtney i hope you can
heal now knowing how deeply sorry i am
she needs your permission to heal i am
so sorry i let you guys down i will
forever work on being better than i was
10 years ago
one year ago six months ago and she was
blocked and courtney said that
that chrissy did not reach out to her
like privately or whatever it's also not
mistake it's not a mistake like telling
someone to kill themselves is like not a
mistake like that's so
that's so crazy to even call it that
that's something and i hate my biggest
thing too is when people use under the
guise of trolling like you can't just
like be an
apple to people yeah like i know people
are like right like i've trolled
like everyone that like hated me like i
never was a mean to anyone i wasn't
calling people [ __ ] i wasn't telling
people to kill themselves it was all
about like me and then people like
eating
when you say you're a troll it implies
like oh i didn't mean it or like
i'm just trying to make i'm just no
that's not a troll oh my god i didn't
interview someone recently i didn't read
someone else and said that they were
just trolling and i'm like no
trolling is not like abusing people's
like mental health like coming for
people calling you
that's not like if you're if you're if
you're harassing someone that's not
trolling like that's not a troll you
can't and i hate that like
specifically females are getting away
with this i noticed this a lot people
are like oh she's a troll or whatever
it's just like no they're not trolling
like it's so
it's so [ __ ] annoying christie is not
trying to well tru trolling is like
saying something you don't necessarily
believe with to get a reaction
how is that when you're in the dms right
they're stuck harassing people's not
trolling that's literally being an
[ __ ]
literally like abusing people like it's
a little bit different like ellen who's
like i don't know what anyone's talking
about like i just
think we need to cancel all those people
because like if you're self-aware and
you get it and you change cool but if
you're not and you're just like
completely out of touch and like tone
deaf and everything like that like you
should be canceled
including ellen ellen's like oh my god
like you know literally is canceled her
show
but she's like i don't know what people
are talking about toxic work environment
it's like what
you're literally the toxicity in your
work environment okay anyways speaking
of toxicity
ellen and chrissy because i know we're
only talking about males and we're
trying right opportunities
we just said did you know naomi campbell
would used to hang out with epstein on
his island
we don't cancel her i mean how are you
saying someone on the face at this point
who hasn't been on epstein's island
not me not you i've been twice i'm on
the flight log
no i'm just kidding no i haven't but
it's like it's like what's going on with
these people can we not just fly with
old predators to the private island how
much is it to
ask i feel like i like the level of like
money and
i want to be more famous or more rich i
don't want to even leave my house i
don't want to leave my house let alone
go to fly to someone's island what a
nightmare what are you
doing i'm moving our compound with us no
that's too much
hey dude i've got my own island where i
have like this weird greek temple where
we make human sacrifices you want to
come
spend the weekend bro have you seen the
weird greek temple
like what the f is that human sacrifice
is not it
bro that [ __ ] is so not cool
yeah that's a brave stance but it's but
a good one yeah
all right speaking of toxicity since
we're just attacking all the dumbass
bros of youtube keemstar
who as you know is the probably the
worst person alive as i continue to
emphasize
uh a little thing came up that i wanted
to talk about
um keemstar i can't now by the way i
def noodles posted this like long old
clip of keemstar saying to me
he goes to his f he's streaming and he
goes everybody go to h3h3 and
send him a tweet that says death to all
jews
and i this was like oh you haven't seen
this well no i saw it recently for the
first time and i was like wow even for
keemstar that's crazy
and so then he lies about it he goes
h3h3 is taking it out of context
can't believe i have to make a video
saying this
but i have to because i'm in a sea of
slander
and lies from h3h3 ethan klein you guys
know this is true by now
and you're probably exhausted by this uh
trust me i am too
but here's the new thing on his new
podcast
he is playing a clip of me saying let's
get into the news or whatever and he's
trying to make it look like i'm doing
some type of hitler salute or something
um and he's playing audio clip where i
say
death to all you you know the line yes i
don't know
you know well i don't want him to take
my audio out of context i already got it
and i'm thinking to myself like i never
said this like
what where is this coming from i like i
have no
anyway he he goes on to say that he was
covering the pewdiepie story
when pewdiepie got into all that drama
because he had those guys on five or six
jews
so then okay so he says ethan's
slandering me you guys know it all by
now
and then so deaf noodles comes out with
the receipts and it's so
[ __ ] good watch this [ __ ]
h3h3 death to all jews
that's what this is everybody tweet
he literally goes he's slandering me you
guys are all tired of it by now he took
it from the pewdiepie story and then
death noodles was like [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] done everybody tweet at
[ __ ] h3h3 death to all jews
how do you survive that yeah everybody's
talking about how do you describe that
i mean yeah but i think he i think his
thing is he likes to be
awful like that's he likes it he enjoys
being an awful person
and so like well at least own it because
he was lying about it
people we call out don't want to be
awful right you are trying to help
people i look i'm always on your side if
we hate keemstar
oh by the way i'm just saying like
calling him out he loves it because he
doesn't want to be better he thinks he's
like i don't think he loves it i don't
think he loves it he's lying about it
he's saying it wasn't him and now he's
bitched out
by the way this is the clip he's talking
about which is hilarious i love that
he's trying to defend
i said i was born in the wrong
generation that's the thumbnail we made
about him
and it's so funny was he doing that well
yeah it's just a joke he wasn't actually
doing a knockout
i don't know but it's fun it's so funny
to me that he's actually being like guys
they didn't do a nazis
in the wrong generation but he did say
death to all jews so there you have it
ah
yeah i feel like keemstar is an
equivalent to someone that i really
dislike like i feel like we both have
these like
but i don't talk about that person
because i just feel like that person
like gets off on it you know what i mean
like i mean i'm all for like talk about
it bring awareness to it but i'm just
you know what i mean like
i think he like loves the back and forth
like he loves being angry and making
these videos and stuff you know and he
doesn't want to be better or
you know i don't i the thing is like
okay i know who you're talking about
and she's like and she's like a spaz
right and annoying
but keemstar is actually an evil
horrible person no but this person i
believe
but the things that no but the things
that she's the keemstar has done
is things that nobody on the internet
has even come close to doing
you know she's up to kids like she's
done some bad [ __ ] to kids bro
there's no comparison i don't agree with
no comparison
because this guy does i think get off on
being like trolling being like saying
what's happening even comparing them is
like
so you don't know you don't know the
stuff that i've been through with this
person like it is really
bad it's really bad harassment like to
okay let me okay let me try to prove to
you that he's the worst person because
i'm
not saying he's not wait wait i have an
example that i think is gonna change
your mind i think it's just triggering
him more to be more aggressive towards
you i think it's great because nobody
else
because nobody calls him out because
he's such a toxic piece of [ __ ] people
are all scared of him because they know
that he's like such a psychologist yeah
there's nothing
he's like you're right ethan's right so
like is it doesn't it get exhausting i
like he said i'm all for it but
he's not listen if you want to but i
just think it triggers him more to be
more aggressive towards you you know no
it's fine
i don't care if he talks about me well i
don't give a [ __ ] okay i think it's
funny
that he's actually being like i didn't
say death to all jews and then he's like
oh wait i did say
because he starts making things up like
ice actually assaulted him and then it
gets a little bit stressful
because it's not it's not real and like
you can't combat lies
and it's the same sort of thing that i
was dealing with with my other person
it's like i can't combat a lie like
there's nothing to do and
that's what it's just a little stressful
because i don't want to keep triggering
him because he is so unhinged and i
don't you know but i don't like to
let him have that power over me where
it's like oh he's so [ __ ]
crazy that i can never call him out
because he has no
limit to trying to ruin your life that's
that's the part of me
that's like i do not [ __ ] ever back
down
against people because of oh
he's that's his thing i'm so [ __ ]
crazy and psycho and i
lie and so like that's [ __ ] but
you've caught him out on this he
deserves to be called out more than
anybody yeah but it's like the same
things you're calling him out for you
wait
a minute i've got more okay first of all
in response to him he actually made a
video being like okay i did say that he
said i'm not sorry for what i said
i'm sorry i got caught huge difference
you dumb [ __ ]
he just i thought that was funny he said
it to this girl who's like yeah
that's funny can we appreciate that sure
thank you
okay thank you so much okay
that's not it though um oh this is him
admitting that he sent people to say
death tool jews to me
i'll just watch it for a minute i have
been caught
in 4k i'm busted
so frustrating he's such a [ __ ]
psycho okay but here's what i wanted to
show you okay
that's a great sound bite by the way you
know we're gonna grab that
um this is an audio from back in the day
okay keemstar used to be a streamer uh
trash talker and this is a this was
according to the person that recorded
this
here i'll read it to you because
keemstar says this was a joke or
whatever
and i'll just say keemstar says that he
had his wife came out and made a
statement like i was just kidding
okay but let me read this this is my
video i really don't know
what this their argument was about back
in the day this video
was all trash talking and i caught this
incident between keem and his girlfriend
at the time
who he had a kid with i see him doing
well for himself now and good on him
just being a hate figure which got him
rich well i made this vid
he was virtually unknown at the time and
was somebody at the time was basically
we were bullying
we grew up and i guess he didn't and he
just liked kids attention
okay so this is a video again the
keemstar
is this is one of these things that's
like uh bro this is something you can't
live down okay
here answer my [ __ ] question answer
my
question answer my questions
answer my [ __ ] question how are you
doing answer my question
guys you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
answer my question
answer my questions
how
that's what i'm saying i think there's
this person's like really like disturbed
me too
but i think why should we be scared of
him we calling out everybody
on the whole internet using me of rape
yeah he's a [ __ ] liar psychopath
why should we be afraid to call him out
because he's so because he's so toxic i
just
i think that's [ __ ] i think this is
something that's like a police situation
if he's like hitting people and stuff
like that you know what i mean like just
like antagonizing him i don't know it
gives me just like a stick
i understand you don't want to get
involved but like because it just like
really affects me and i just i don't
yeah because he's
he's shameless and he's psychotic and
he'll lie about you
and as he's done about me my whole
career he has no reason to go after you
other than that we're friends sitting
next to you you know you could do it on
like h3 or something like a podcast
where you brought yourself because i
just i know he comes from me and it's
like i'm really trying to stay away from
him because it really
really [ __ ] with me i feel like that's
[ __ ] up that he uses that as a defense
to scare people but i know what you mean
it's like it's really affecting me it's
not it has nothing to do with him no i
know exactly what you mean though
it's like that other person even though
you know they're not equally the same
it's like i'd just rather not put myself
through that like it's a lot on my
psyche and stuff these people that are
like really upset right
it's not mike or something you know what
i mean like a back and forth just like
that other girl we don't talk about it's
like there's a lot that like some
there's some people that are [ __ ] up
too much
i get it i i see your point um
anyway he said about this clip that his
girlfriend
came out and made a statement saying was
all sketch and all a joke which is what
he says about everything
even though he was a nobody at the time
and it was randomly recorded so i don't
know what's the joke exactly
um yeah it's really messed up i don't
know
uh bryce hall wants to fight me
oh yeah oh my god he was weirdly
aggressive on twitter yeah but i barely
mentioned him on our last podcast
we barely mentioned because i said way
more [ __ ] about him yeah and i feel like
i was kind of like
coming from like baton i was like oh
this is kind of like to me it felt
light-hearted but like i mean
he's not he kind of seems like he's a
little like he just has a little issues
too
he goes uh damn but i think he wants i
think he wants the back and forth right
room he likes the back and forth yeah
and that's fine and i'll give it to him
you are are you gonna go back and forth
well no i didn't i didn't respond
i want to read it but i i figured it
would be fun to read mia was like more
like i don't know maybe i'm digging i
just
felt a little more lighthearted or not
were you like i don't know no no yeah oh
well compared to keemstar everybody's
like a [ __ ] fairy
i know now it's like a breath of yeah
compared to kim star it's like oh you're
a
dog like if i saw bryce i'd be like dog
what's up but do you know what i mean
like there's like mentally stable
there's
unstable yes i know exactly what mike
malek and that other guy they're they're
well they're
with it you know what i mean but then
there's some people that are just not
well they say like when it comes to like
like true personality disorder like
psychopaths yeah
or like narcissists then the best thing
to do is to disengage
yeah because you don't want to be i
think that's what i'm like saying yeah
yeah yeah i i i
was like bryce hall i don't think he's
like no he's not he's not a like
they're like normal douche he's like
clinically dangerous dude yeah there's
only like three people i've just engaged
with and i would say
i know i know what you mean but first
yeah i know we don't have to talk about
him anymore
bryce hall is so much more like light we
like brazen now we're like okay he's
cool
he's a great i'm he's a great guy
compared to the last day we just talked
about
yeah i won't talk about keemstar on the
show anymore yeah i think that might be
for me for my sake i know what you're
saying but like maybe i won't
i won't bring it up anymore but if it's
something that affects you i'll bring
i'll bring
that's the pro it's the to me i feel
like it really affect
i don't know i felt felt like a
conversation and i but i understand i'll
leave the death toll jewish sound bites
on
after dark or just your own history
don't put gila in it either maybe just
do it on your own well he's already gone
he's been off the rails
he goes after ela he goes he calls it i
guess she like yeah whatever
well anyway speaking of the great great
dude totally stable breaks all
um i what did we say about him on the
last podcast we said um
because he called the girl a [ __ ] and i
was like [ __ ] all right you remember he
called that girl [ __ ] for bumping into
him
like the [ __ ] is wrong and i was like
[ __ ] he said yo
h productions i think you should worry
about that fat fat
lawsuit trillion instead of talking [ __ ]
about me you old [ __ ] it's like i can do
both bro i mean kind of aggressive but i
get it i get it
it's also i don't know what qualifies as
a fat lawsuit
i think i'm included in this next tweet
he says i don't know why these grandpas
and grandmas
dude it's like bro seriously i think
this is where i thought it was more
parody because i was like oh okay like
you know
i mean whatever i would love to see
bryce hall in 14 years you're not gonna
be on social media
i'll have no hair that's what i predict
yeah he'll definitely be like he's in
love of course
he'll be like in the corporate offices
of like wood ranch fire girl like he'll
be like
you know yeah he's got a server he'll be
a manager of wood ranch
he'll put it in the time he'll put in
the time you know
he'll have a wood ranch shell oh yeah
he'll make sure the biscuits are really
buttery and good i love but this is i'm
hungry
yeah same rice you're making me hungry
dog they're the kind of people i like to
see
come and go you know what i mean because
their egos get so big and it's like that
doesn't last anywhere he johnnied up if
he had a big ego you know they get
knocked out you know what i mean like we
should change our podcast to the
bullying
two fat losers bully kids the two
people bullied who now bully yeah we
should be against bullying
but we're not because we were bullied he
said i don't get why these grandma and
grandpa's always critiqued 17 to 21 year
old kids
if they weren't [ __ ] up about her age
sorry that these things called phones
that document [ __ ] now instead of the
rocks you used to communicate it's kind
of funny
i guess but i think i think also like
yeah
but i think he's exaggerated i don't
think i go after 17 year olds maybe you
do
some uh yeah when like [ __ ] jake
charles is sexting a 17 year old but we
don't go after 17 year olds though
um um yeah well you know it's what we're
that's what we do this is what we do
online i don't know
yeah [ __ ] it um oh but then a guy
he likes the show i'm going to be honest
so i don't know you've been mentioned
just excited when people mention me yeah
i was like all right cool dude you made
a whole industry out of that you made
like a hundred thousand dollars after
that match
get excited yeah i do get excited when
people mention me i was like okay here
we go
i weigh though now i balance what's
worth it and what's not and i try to go
for the mentally stable like even if
they're dumbasses i do try and go for a
mentally stable dumbass
there's not many people like you know
the dude we just talked about
there's really nobody like him on the
whole internet right there's not
okay and you can have fun and argue and
[ __ ] on each other like my relationship
with the paul brothers or
mike or even face blinks i know that
it's like there's a certain boundary
that normal people don't cross
right right yeah
okay you brought it up you said
something about you
about what okay we don't know about
children okay so bryce hall
um one other thing about bryce hall
that's so funny because he acts like
such a tough guy you know he does
these videos where he shows up and wants
to fight people i think he wanted to do
that on our podcast
too he was like let me roll up he dm'd
me oh that's what pissed him off
what because he dm'd me on instagram and
i sh
talked about him what did you say you
didn't say anything about that no i
didn't say anything bad about him but he
fight you
you want him you want me to fight bryce
hall you're like his uh verbiage
well anyway he's such a [ __ ] it turns
out this guy actually took his hat at a
party
the one time he actually had a chance to
actually get enough physical conflict
with someone and he bitched out
look how unaggressive he is
anyway whatever i don't know the guy's a
douche who took his hat too so i'm not
trying to celebrate i don't
i was i was getting too free to be on
the show bryce i was kind of i was an
advocate for it but the funny part
oh no the video is not the video's down
i don't know if i'm a grandma i mean
maybe a mom or something about a girl
well when you
when we grew up all we had was rocks
kind of funny though i mean i guess
well anyway they're part three the guy
who got his hat said he had like a
massive lice infection from wearing
braces
that was very great i think so because
he just deleted it don't lay shame i had
lice
when did you have life in the fourth
grade i had a great place really short
okay good i thought you could stay as an
adult
right now i don't think adults get it
because i've had my head on i had life
when i was a kid
but like everybody at my school had lice
it was like a life infestation
every all the kids had lice it was crazy
i was the only one and people thought i
was dirty because my mom like chopped my
hair off and stuff
i have a nice picture of my short hair
you have a life pick yeah
oh that's so gross yeah i just remember
all the kids had to go to the nurse
during school
and they were all like doing like this
like checking for lice and they're like
you got lice
and i had to use like special shampoo to
kill those yeah then it's like knicks or
knit or something like you have to cut
your hair damn girl you were really
infested i had a lot yeah
my mom's like [ __ ] they're like playing
playing no games with those lights
yeah yikes all right well we slammed it
that's our podcast it was a weird it was
a roller coaster bullying the bullies
taking the taking the well i think we
bullied a little but i think if you eat
what's the eye for tonight and i further
than i
i get on the defense if i if i seem
angry and sometimes i get a little
defensive if i feel if i feel
offended i got a little offended by the
mic thing i it did trigger me a little
bit
i know but that's why i was a little
aggressive same thing with jason when i
see his face it's
triggering like we shouldn't talk about
jesus either anymore because i feel like
yeah okay let's put an embargo on
keemstar
and jason on this show yeah and then the
other person that won't be named and the
other person that won't be named
baltimore
yeah voldemort
the whole the whole trio just triggered
me so i feel like i used to feel that
way about
keem but i've just i knew that in my
i'm not comparing it to your situation
but i was like i have to just take this
[ __ ] on
because he kept coming at me with all
these lies and all these lies and i was
like bro i can't live
with this dude just lying about me so i
was like all right let's go to the bat
and i just put it all on the table in
this three-part documentary and since
then it's like i feel so liberated
because i can [ __ ] talk about him and
say the [ __ ] that i want to say about
him was that he's
a dangerous human being that should
probably be in a [ __ ] insane asylum
next to the joker
two-face he's like a batman villain bro
okay
well if you want to hear more about that
h3 podcast ethan off the rails on every
thursday
where there's no female co-host to guide
yeah ela makes a joke that i got sued
i was doing off the rails that's our
wednesday episode for one month and now
i'm being sued by triller
because it was off the rails see maybe
you shouldn't do those anymore
it's funny i don't know true fans love
off the rails
i just stand after dark i love after
dark okay
thank you everyone for watching it's
been such a tremendous fun
time with my bestie not even my friend
me
bestie the bestie bestie trisha paytas
yeah
crushing it on only fans point 1.001
you're probably you might be even number
one how do you tell who's number one
i don't think you can i'm in touch with
like the creator of only fans so
you should find out if you're number one
i'm sure i'm not number one i'm sure
like
riley or lana they're pretty high up oh
they are they're popular on that maybe
maybe filming that content
good for them yeah i'm actually i
actually think only fans the culture of
that is so cool how
because the porn industry has been so
traditionally like predatory yeah
and these girls are making them so much
money and not getting paid anything and
now they're
have all the power they're making
they're becoming literally millionaires
i've made 10 times the amount i've made
on only fans in one year i mean 10 times
the amount that i made in my entire
youtube career
that's crazy crazy but someone like lana
rose she's like becoming like a
multi-millionaire
amazing all right we've got to wrap it
up shout out to lana we stand lana mike
yeah
you're a douche thanks for watching
[Music]
you